a special counsel has been appointed to
investigate Joe Biden's handling of
classified documents after it was
revealed that uh in his garage next to
his Corvette was apparently a stack of
classified documents from when he was
vice president so uh that's rather
shocking and he was asked about this and
he just said oh it's locked in my garage
next to my Corvette and then everyone
pulled up this old video where his
garage is very flimsily secured if at
all from a thin little garage door and
you can see just a big stack of boxes
where people are assuming that's
probably where it was well according to
all of the hit pieces we saw against
Trump going back for the past several
months well this means that Joe Biden
has to Forfeit his office because he had
classified documents from when he wasn't
president but we'll see a special
counsel is being appointed and I'm not
convinced anything will actually happen
unless you believe the conspiracy
theories they think this is how the
Democrats actually get rid of Biden
bring in Kamala Harris and then prepare
for a better 2024 or something like that
we'll talk about that plus we got some
Twitter files Revelations apparently
Twitter and uh well we'll talk about
this Democrats are being warned about
fake Russian Bots plus censorship and
we've got some special guests who are
going to be uh talking about censorship
which I think will be particularly
interesting and then I really want to
talk about Illinois's gun ban because
this one's fascinating Illinois is
Banning assault weapons as they describe
it but local sheriffs are saying they
won't do it and they're threatened being
threatened with removal from their jobs
so we'll get into all that but before we
do head over to timcast.com become a mem
number by clicking that join us button
to help support our work as a member
you'll get access to our exclusive
members only segments of this show we're
gonna have a members only show coming up
for you at about 11 p.m tonight should
be a whole lot of fun and as a member
you're also supporting our cultural
Endeavors this Saturday I hope you join
us in DC at Freedom Plaza where I'll be
skating that's about it I'll skate give
away some boards because I got some
boards in the back of the truck and uh
you can have it just show up and have
fun we're going to assert ourselves in
these cultural spaces and with your
support we'll keep doing more things
like that so don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends joining
us today to talk about this and so much
more is the krasensteins how's it going
guys who which one one which one he
wants to introduce yourself first yeah
so I'm Brian uh probably know us from
Twitter
um we were that Trump reply guys I guess
a lot of people cause uh but but we've
done a lot uh we're obviously left left
leaning um but I I think it's important
to kind of communicate and talk to
people you disagree with politically we
created a podcast crash and cast uh
dismantling Division and we interview
people that we disagree with and just
talk about daily stuff and just try and
get along and usually it works out
sounds good I don't know Ed did you want
anything yeah um yeah crash and kiss new
you can follow us on YouTube it's just
crashing chaos I want to give a shout
out to my friend Mike mansuedo in Los
Angeles or in San Diego he's a huge fan
of Tim cast so just want to say hi yeah
and glad to talk about whatever you want
right on yeah a lot of people are are
commenting saying like you're the Trump
derangement syndrome guys you're like
the most notable Trump reply guys like
any anything Trump would say you were
always on top everyone always saw you
guys we were yeah and then they banned
you and I think it was BS I thought I
think they made up a fake reason to ban
you guys well so so I I mean it it's
it's hard to tell if they actually
thought we were doing what they said we
were doing which was buying our accounts
and buying engagement and uh we proved
to them that we weren't we showed them
the emails of when we when we purchased
the accounts uh but purchase they can
it's not purchasing when we sign
registered accounts yet before he didn't
slip I guess no no we didn't actually
buy our accounts and uh and it came at a
time when Twitter was Banning a lot of
conservatives of course and I kind of
felt like maybe they used us as an
example uh they looked for something
they they maybe saw something and
thought that we did actually buy our
accounts I don't know I don't believe it
I think we'll talk about it though we'll
save it because there's a lot to talk
about there especially the Twitter file
so thanks for hanging out this should be
a lot of fun actually we got Luke yeah
thanks for coming this should be a great
conversation and I don't know about you
guys but with the way that things are
going I think I'm going to be voting in
uh Brandon for the next upcoming
presidential election and that's why I'm
wearing my let's go Brandon 2024 shirt
if you're with me we could do this I
believe in you we could just write in
the name Brandon 2024 uh if you're with
me get the shirt on
thebestpoliticalshorts.com because you
do that's why I am here Biden fetterman
come on what do you mean well there's
also ligma Johnson which is uh which is
also going to be a very serious
Contender so there's a lot of very uh
you know important people these nuts I
mean they're a lot better than the
official choices so I'm seriously
considering them you should too all
right I'm glad you guys are here we had
the um The Hodgetwins earlier in the
week I don't know if you know them
personally I'd love to get the four of
you in a room together but for so long I
was like oh yeah the brothers twins on
Twitter and I thought it was all the
same people so I'm glad now I put a face
to the name and finally meet you guys
well I mean Crossland what's happening
and I'm search.com as always I was on a
pop culture crisis I forgot to mention
that after the show yesterday but that's
under today anyways let's get started
let's jump into this first story from
apnews.com Garland appoints special
counsel to investigate Biden docs
attorney general Merrick Garland on
Thursday appointed a special counsel to
investigate the presence of classified
documents found at President Joe Biden's
home in Wilmington Delaware and at an
unsecured office in Washington dating
from his time as vice president Robert
Herr a one-time U.S attorney appointed
by former president Donald Trump will
lead the investigation and plans to
begin his work soon his appointment
marks a second time in a few months that
Garland is appointed a special counsel
an extraordinary fact that reflects the
Justice Department's efforts to
independently conduct high-profile
probes in an exceedingly heated
political environment both of those
investigations the early one involving
Trump and documents recovered from his
Mar-A-Lago estate in Florida relate to
the handling of classified information
though there are notable differences
between those cases I love how the media
really really wants to make sure
everybody knows there's notable
differences but they don't ever quite
bring up the fact that PolitiFact ran
this story quote the minute the
president speaks about it to someone he
has the ability to declassify anything
at any time without any process mostly
true reports PolitiFact so if that's the
case what is the issue with Donald
Trump's documents so uh well I'm curious
I mean I think everyone's heard our
thoughts on this I'm wondering what you
guys think you know like I don't think
the issues that at least from what we
see with the with the search warrant
what wasn't classification I think the
issue was the fact that he a obstructed
the investigation
allegedly and B the Espionage Act which
says you can't have defense documents in
your possession when the government
needs them
so so I I don't think I don't think
that's what they're trying to get him on
Trump yeah I don't think they're trying
to get him on on the classification
issue maybe that changes but from what
I've read I think they're going after
him because he basically had government
documents I think one of the big
challenges with the Trump thing is that
we've heard from the Trump side of
things and from early reports that they
they were cooperating but they did let
them come in and it was actually the
FBI's own lock so so the FBI comes in
and says hey you have these documents
just make sure you lock them up and
they're like you got it boss then the
FBI comes back later smashes the lock
and takes the documents yep so so what
happened was so January he leaves office
in May the National Archives is like Hey
listen we believe you have documents and
I don't know if they gave him a list of
documents they thought he had but they
said you have documents where you'd like
them back and then it took seven more
months Trump's lawyers I think it was in
December of 2021 said okay well we we
found some documents then in January
they said here's 15 boxes of documents
and and the following months I think was
February of 2022 the National Archives
comes back and says we still didn't get
all of them we you still have more we
need more documents and
they go back and forth back and forth
and apparently National Archives wasn't
satisfied with how Trump's team was
cooperating so they got a grand jury
subpoena in the spring and then
they went they visited it visited
Mar-A-Lago and Trump's team allowed them
to search the basement I believe the
basement storage room and they came out
there with more documents and the lawyer
signs the signs a declaration saying
we've searched the entire place no more
documents are here
then it turns out there were more there
are more documents but I suppose the
issue is the president has plenary
declassification powers
as the president he is the end-all
be-all of what is classified or what
isn't yeah but you also got to look at
like what's the damage to the country so
like is he taking compartment mentalized
documents that there's one copy of that
somebody else in government now maybe in
the Biden Administration might need for
whatever they're whatever they're
working on is it a danger to the country
and and we don't know we don't know if
that's the case or not but I mean I I
think that like to to figure that out
would be big to just understand the
situation I I can agree I mean if if
there's like a single copy of it they're
like whoa what happened to these files
would be really really bad but that'd be
really really bad outside of trump just
having them because what are we doing
not having important copies but that
still doesn't answer the question of the
so the the reason the president can
declassify anything instantly is because
imagine he's negotiating with Vladimir
Putin to like get out of Ukraine and
then he has to go there and be like well
you know I would negotiate on troop
positioning in Nate in in Poland or
whatever but uh it's classified so I
can't tell you about it like that makes
no sense he needs to literally be like
okay here's where our our shipments and
troops are going in we'll take those out
if you take this so he has to be able to
do that so this looks just overtly
political but even so outside of that I
can certainly understand an argument of
like the greater good like whether or
not Trump has the power to do it you
know maybe we should get those documents
back but then why pursue a criminal
investigation and then you get the media
coming out and saying Trump is under
criminal investigation but Joe Biden is
his documents are facing a special
counsel well they didn't say he's facing
it I think with Trump though
I don't think he was under criminal
investigation until he didn't turn over
the documents at the national Army he
doesn't have to well he does if the
government says they're there but but if
the president even there's not not
classified he still has to turn them
over if the National Archive says these
are government documents we need them
back they're not your personal documents
I suppose I can understand the argument
you're making that their property of but
if they but that's that's an argument
where we'd have to actually look into
determine whether or not he made copies
of these documents but my understanding
was that he has copies of them as the
president and some of the documents were
like his presidential briefings and
stuff like that which if if he can
declassify then he can have but but at
any rate if that was the case pursuing
criminal charges because he's like I
disagree on whether you own this piece
of paper is is kind of it's kind of
silly yeah is it so you can't have
copies of compartmentalized documents so
like classified documents there could be
multiple copies and several people could
add that but if they're
compartmentalized there's only usually
one cup one copy as far as I understand
so if he had that he would have had to
have taken it out of the compartment or
wherever it's at and brought it back to
Mar-A-Lago and then somebody else can't
gain access to that so there actually is
only one copy as far as I know well I
guess we have to get into the what all
of the documents are yeah and then when
were the documents taken if they were
taken after he was no January 20th when
he was leaving the White House
maybe he was no longer president when he
told them so you know you need that
information and I'm pretty sure they
have copy machines in Washington DC to
be a little facetious this year uh but
more importantly it's kind of convenient
that the burden of proof is it's
classified we can't tell you but there's
only one of us and we really really
needed it for what we can't tell you
yeah so we'll never know we I for me
personally I don't think we should give
the burden of Doubt to the doj that
clearly is very political especially
when it came to what happened with Biden
they found Biden's documents on November
2nd a week before the midterm elections
we're now hearing about it I think this
would have had an effect on the election
and I think this is why the doj has been
politicized because this is one clear
example of it and when not just that
it's uh the vice president and Hillary
Clinton and Secretary of State separate
instances do not have the power of
declassification well so the president
does it so there's a
2003 executive order by George Bush I
believe I believe Obama had another
executive office an order in 2 2009
which says the vice president and the
president can both classify documents
and the vice president can declassify
documents that he classified and
also if he is deemed a super in a
supervisory role over the agent who
classified it he can declassify it so
I mean if there are random documents
maybe he didn't have it it depends what
a supervisory role is and I don't think
there's really a clear definition of
that is it vice president of the second
in the executive branch a supervisor of
you know an agent in the CIA we don't
know like I don't know I think that's
something that would have to be
determined by a judge or you know I do
have this I pulled it up this is from
the Washington Times March 2003
executive order signed by George W bush
empowered the vice president to classify
sensitive materials that same executive
order grants declassification powers to
quote the official who authorized the
original classification or a supervisor
official under the executive order vice
presidents are granted the power to
declassify documents they classified
themselves but it's unclear If the vice
president would be viewed as a
supervisory official with the ability to
declassify sensitive documents from the
CIA and other intelligence agencies I
just think it's really convenient that
we got probably 300 articles arguing
that Donald Trump would have to Forfeit
any office or that he was disqualified
for having classified.com comments
literally not even the argument of you
know compartmentalization it was like if
he had classified documents he violated
the records act or whatever and then as
soon as it happens with Joe Biden it
happens twice all of a sudden there's a
debate over well you know actually the
vice president the president can
declassify things it sounds like a
cop-out yeah I I think it kind of
depends on intent right so like did
Trump take them purposely out of out of
the White House or wherever and keep
store them at Mar-A-Lago I I think we
know more of his intent just because the
fact that he refused to turn them over
knowing that he had I disagree I mean
the documents were in boxes of random
things like like briefings and Time
Magazine clippings it really does sound
like in both instances of Biden and
Trump they had boxes of paperwork they
just carried out not realized what was
in it yeah I I think until we see more
information you have to assume that he
didn't he didn't intentionally do it
right neither of them intentionally did
it unless you have you know witnesses
that saw him or heard him say you know
no we have to keep these we don't want
to turn them over to that National
Archives beats their mind I believe
they're mine the government shouldn't
have a right to take them so so I think
we have to hear the information that
comes out we have to see the evidence
and I guess we'll eventually see that I
don't know how long it's going to take
I'd like to repeal this executive order
in the meantime George Bush gave Dick
Cheney way too much power he let him run
the war basically let him put his
Halliburton company in Iraq to make all
this money and this stupid stupid rule
that he gave the vice president with no
command Authority the ability to
classify and declassifying those insane
yeah well Dick Cheney was pretty much
the president uh he's pretty much
calling the shots here let's just be
real here but the little that we know
about these classified documents and I
don't think we're going to learn more
about them because the doj clearly is
very political they clearly have a side
here so I don't see them releasing any
kind of more information here I mean
we'll see what happens I'm always
skeptical but the few things that we do
know is that they were they were related
to Ukraine to Iran and the United
Kingdom so these were specific documents
dealing with uh intelligence foreign
Services what's happening
internationally so I I think with with
that context especially with with where
they were located at a think tank that's
connected to Chinese money there is some
possible questions here about what
information was shared who got it
especially with the big business ties
between Ukraine and the Biden's the
Chinese government and the bidens I
think there's a lot more room for a lot
more corruption here uh especially with
you know Biden being a career politician
rather than Donald Trump who's kind of
been obfuscated away from politics and
kind of pushed away from everybody
that's my initial kind of reaction what
do you guys think I I think that I
definitely agree I think there should be
a special counsel and there should be an
investigation so I I think they're
handling both both Trump and Biden the
correct way special counsels uh I mean
you can say that the doj is politicized
but it's a it's an independent special
counsel being appointed I think he was
actually appointed by Trump uh this her
guy I think the Attorney General that's
uh or overseeing it in in one of the
jurisdictions was appointed by Trump but
I don't know about the special counsel
guy to be honest I think her I think her
was a trump nominee or Trump appointment
I don't know I guess what's the name her
Robert her yes so like I I think that I
think we just got to wait and see and
and I hope they investigate Biden just
as vigorously as they they're
investigating Trump and we figure this
out I I don't think I don't think many
Democrats disagree that that we should
figure out all the facts behind this and
it could be good it could be bad
whatever it is I think it's important we
know right I think at this point
Democrats are probably excited for the
prospect of getting rid of Biden and
getting something I heard that one
before yeah I mean you've heard people
saying that basically it's like here's
how you get rid of the guy because
because apparently he's playing on
running again he's already campaigning
and it's like he's in a weak position if
it ends up being DeSantis against about
it I don't think Biden wins
I I I agree that he's probably too old
to run for a second term I I would I
would love for the Democrats to nominate
somebody that's younger
um I I think that if it was Trump Biden
I think Biden would win I think if it
was DeSantis Biden I think Biden's going
to have a difficult time who would you
guys vote for uh DeSantis or Biden it's
still Biden okay why though just because
I I agree more with his views
well I can certainly understand from
like especially the culture war and all
that stuff but uh
what has Biden done or what are his
views that you think are are good or
that are worth giving a second term to I
I think he's done a lot a lot of good I
I think that uh I mean I could name
several things I think the chips act
which brought manufacturing of computer
chips back the United States I think
that's great for manufacturing here but
also great for uh I think our national
security uh the packed act with the burn
pit thing which heat signed and do law
the uh the cap on senior uh prescription
drug costs at two thousand dollars I
think that's great I think there's a lot
of old people in the United States who
aren't even buying drugs that they need
because of the expenses and I I I love
the fact that he signed that new law
a lot of these things I think you know
before the show we were talking about
how uh we had Destiny on what's his name
Steve Steve Benelli Benelli yeah I
thought it was Bonnell wasn't it Donald
I thought there's an island but uh you
know I was saying like obviously on a
lot of core issues like healthcare you
know rights of the workers bringing jobs
back bringing chip manufacturing like
we're gonna that's a good one by the way
oh I think it's Stephen Bonnell the
second so I thought that was an eye
sorry Steve there you go I was like I
was waiting on there but uh one of the
issues I take uh
the most important thing foreign policy
for me I often go off on foreign policy
like we had a lot of eliyahu he's a
reporter for us and then we got into a
yelling match because he's like he
called himself jokingly the resident
neocon because he was saying like we
should be at war in these countries we
should be stopping communism we should
be it should be a unipolar world where
the U.S is in control and my attitude is
kind of like okay I get that I
understand why you'd argue that but I'm
I'm pretty much against U.S intervention
in all these countries effectively
invading countries to remove their
government and their cultures and impose
our own will and stuff like that so when
it comes to Joe Biden you know I've seen
what Joe Biden did in in when he was
vice president and it was I I I think
corruption is an understatement right as
soon as he gets he gets put in charge of
the war in Iraq his brother gets
lucrative contracts we see the expansion
of the wars in the Middle East under the
Obama Administration we see the Drone
killings of children which okay fine
that's you know that's on Barack Obama
like the killing of Abdullah but also
other American citizens like Anwar
lalaki under Donald Trump we certainly
had some bad things there's a Commando
right in Yemen which the people their
claim killed an eight-year-old American
Girl
it's a bad claim it's not the same thing
as what we know that Obama did Kill
Abdul Rahman al-alalaki but then Trump
tries negotiating peace with North Korea
actually walking through the DMZ into
North Korea with no security detail he
gets us the Abraham Accords he gets you
know uh pulling our troops out of Syria
at least as much as he could without the
U.S military actually lying to him and
us about how many troops we had there
setting a timeline for Afghanistan
withdrawal so those things for me are
extremely important and I can certainly
understand you know you've mentioned
those domestic policies but I'm curious
your thoughts on that regard I mean when
it comes to war Joe Biden is in my
opinion indefensible
yeah I mean do you bring up some good
points about International policy and I
I tend to focus more on National stuff
stuff that's happening in our country
I'm I'm pretty much against War too so I
mean it's hard to argue with some of
that stuff uh you know I mean how many
wars are we in right now oh man we don't
even know about it yeah a lot of them
are clandestine a lot of them are
secrets that's because of Donald Trump a
lot of that's well there's the proxy
there's the proxy these drone Wars
I I want to expand on that because
there's the proxy war in Ukraine there's
also expanded operations right now in
Africa there's limited operations in
Syria uh very limited uh covert Ops in
Libya
um always a troop presence in um Iraq
still with fighting between the Sunni
shiis and the Iranians also getting
involved there
um a couple years ago we were bombing
places in the Philippines I don't know
if we're still doing that now a lot of
this again is covert so we moved from
over War to of course a lot of
clandestine War limited War the we kind
of implemented the Henry Kissinger
Doctrine and to answer your question uh
there's probably a lot more Wars that
were involved in that we actually know
about yeah and I and I I just mean
official Wars we got out of Afghanistan
of course but no and and
um anti-interventionist I I don't think
we should be dabbling in all these
countries I I don't have a
a negative opinion on us helping Ukraine
know I I think that
given given what's happening over there
I think we do need to help them just so
that Russia's aggression doesn't spread
throughout the rest of Europe uh I I
mean I I hate to see us supplying
weapons that are killing people but at
the same time I fear more what Russia
would do if they went unchecked well how
do you feel about u.s's direct
involvement in Ukraine with our
spiritual forces on the ground I I don't
I wouldn't I wouldn't like that well
that's happening right now and also
Ukrainian soldiers are being sent to
Oklahoma in order to get specific
American training I also forgot one very
important war and that's the war in
Yemen which is still continuing right
now it's a larger proxy war between the
United States and Saudi Arabian
Coalition which is creating one of the
worst humanitarian crises in the world
right now I think these issues do matter
and and I think not a lot of people take
them seriously because they happen
outside of the United States but I
definitely think we definitely need more
of a conversation about this because the
war in Ukraine it's it's it's a very
dangerous situation and I understand
that you know a lot of people are vying
for influence or vying for territory or
vying for power but I think it's clearer
than ever if you guys agree or disagree
that the United States and other Western
powers like the United Kingdom have
prevented peace deals have prevented a
stop to this larger proxy conflict and
have prolonged it and are prolonging it
by giving more weapons to it making sure
that it won't it won't stop anytime soon
which I think is tragic for the people
of Ukraine tragic for the people in
Europe and also tragic for everyone else
in the world that's of course this
larger proxy war is also creating a
humanitarian crisis when it comes to
energy resources fertilizer and
affecting some of the poorest people uh
in the world you have a a peace deal
between Russia and Ukraine would require
Ukraine to give Russia something that
they didn't have before the war started
right and and I mean when it comes to
peace deals in the negotiations every
side uh has to give something up so
Russia would give something up Ukraine
would give something up I mean we
reached the point where even Henry
Kissinger uh an absolute war criminal
The Butcher of Cambodia is coming out
publicly saying guys this is getting out
of hand we need a peace deal here so
when it comes to negotiations both both
of the parties are going to have to
concede on something but it's hard to
say okay you know Russia is should gain
for invading Ukraine like so if they
agree to a peace deal now what to stop
them from two months later saying we're
invading again and we're gonna inch
farther and we want another peace deal
and we're going to do the same thing in
another tomb you know
if you give if you give Russia something
they're going to be like we can get
something and they're I mean well that's
that's what they would be saying on the
other side too this is the Perpetual
yeah giving up their land not always
that's one potential stipulation but the
first original peace deal that was
actually sabotaged by the West Was that
uh Russia go back to its original
territories before uh the War uh started
and then we had Boris Johnson come to
Ukraine and said no way you're agreeing
to this specific peace deal so what are
the parameters I mean you're you're
bringing up one parameter if that's on
the negotiation table it at least should
be negotiated but we're even prevented
from coming to the table and negotiating
which I think is absolutely crazy and
rooting for more war when there's so
many things at stake here when there's
so many innocent lives being lost here
is just absolutely crazy in my opinion
and this is my answer you know you're
mentioning like you concerned more about
domestic policy and I can I completely
understand that but how many years was
it where Flint's pipes were not fixed
and these kids are getting you know
there's like legionnaires in the older
population LED another contaminants and
now we're learning in a bunch of
different cities across this country so
that's why when when AOC first announced
the green New Deal when it was very very
rudimentary when it was just like this
idea of we're going to rebuild
infrastructure and massively invest in
renewable energies I was 100 on board I
was like this sounds amazing then she
puts out this document where it's like
once we do away with Air transport and
farting cows which I understand was a
joke but I was just like I don't
understand what free free college for
people of color has to do with fixing
pipes in places like flint and the
response I got from people a lot of
people on the left was well it's all
tied to the same problem and I'm like no
no it literally isn't kids are drinking
lead and instead of spending that you
know was it 30 million dollars or
however which was going to cost to fix
these pipes we're blowing up people in
foreign countries and I think the reason
we're doing it is because the U.S will
do anything to maintain the Petro dollar
that the the the world Reserve currency
will stay the US dollar so we give money
away to Pakistan for gender studies
programs because as it means they'll
spend it because it means everyone will
maintain confidence so we neglect the
things that are actually going on here
at home they throw crumbs out meanwhile
the southern border is completely just
shattered and you've got this you've got
people and children dying in the river
crawling to the desert they ignore those
issues it feels like they're just
offering up whatever they can to keep
people placated while they actually
siphon away the resources from the
people in this country for the issues of
blowing people up overseas and more
importantly when it comes to Ukraine my
view of Ukraine is to go back to what
you were saying about Ukraine went to
give something up I don't I don't
actually view it that way and this is
kind of a hard thing to say because I
have Ukrainian friends and it's really
difficult to talk to them about this but
Ukraine wouldn't be giving up anything
because there is no Ukraine there's a
proxy land between Russia and United
States it's been there since the fall of
the Soviet Union and the U.S and Russia
I should say nato and Russia have been
playing dirty games in that territory
Russia regrets giving it up with the
fall of the Soviet Union they think was
a mistake they need Crimea as a warm
water Port access to the black C to the
Suez Mediterranean Etc et cetera and
they're mad that happened so they want
to take that first then they're running
the risk because they only have that
bridge so they want a land bridge that's
why they want the donbass region the
United States of course is doing
influence operations through usaid and
other organizations in Ukraine to gain
influence you end up in 2014 I'm
actually there I'm interviewing people
about this yes many of ukrainians
outright are like we would rather be
with the EU than Russia because we
remember the Soviet Union and it was bad
but then the president gets removed
flees to Russia you get zelenski instead
you get the whole Fiasco with barisma
Hunter Biden Joe Biden and all of that
corruption and then I look at it like
you've got barisma Energy company
surprise surprise gazprom has
effectively an a monopoly in in Europe
it's Russia's Monopoly through gas prom
through Ukraine the U.S starts putting
its its resources and assets into
Ukraine in the energy sector notably
Hunter Biden as well as a former CIA
director or something working at barisma
a prosecutor Victor shokun is then
investigating Michaela zlachevski the
founder of this company for corruption I
think 12 to 14 different investigations
Joe Biden then flies there says if you
don't fire the prosecutor you're not
getting a billion dollars which is an
illegal quid pro quo I'm not saying he
did it to protect his son but his son
did work for the company did make money
from that the investigations were
happening and it was illegal for him to
do
everything together and I'm just like
you know what I see I see a guy Joe
Biden who when he was the vice president
was placed in charge of the war in Iraq
and then immediately his brother got
lucrative multi-million dollar contracts
to build housing in other buildings and
other Construction in that country
surprise surprise a Politico wrote an
article called Biden Inc where they go
over all of the lucrative deals the
Biden families just fallen into
in relation to the position of Joe Biden
so now we're looking at Ukraine Joe
Biden's dumping a hundred plus billion
dollars just constantly saying give more
money give more money give more money
zelenski is refusing to negotiate and
saying we will not Surrender by the way
U.S give us more money and I'm sitting
here being like can we fix our border
can we fix the pipes can we make sure
these kids are getting clean drinking
water can we stop blowing up people
overseas my view of this whole thing is
that you've got a corrupt parasite class
like Joe Biden and and not just him but
many of the Republicans as well and they
just seek to extract as much as possible
for themselves and I think what they're
probably doing at this point is
transferring their resources to like
Panama because we learned it from the
Panama papers so they can put it in
holding so that when the U.S finally
implodes because they've extracted
everything they can they're gonna send
it over to China where State capitalism
will favor them long story short
it's a good story
well okay so I I mean I I don't disagree
that we shouldn't that we should be
concentrating more on
America and what's happening in this
country
um a lot of your Joe Biden stuff I
disagree with I think that Victor shoken
was pretty much wanted to be the whole
Western World our allies all wanted him
ousted because he was a corrupt
prosecutor and he wasn't actually
Prosecuting people he should have been
Prosecuting but like who I mean if we're
talking about corrupted politicians in
Ukraine there's all Ukraine is known for
corrupting politicians you know but
sorry these guys to address that I can
agree right the the West did want Victor
shoken out that was the policy the issue
is that when Victor shulkin got ousted
Michael zlachevski this is what Biden
said he said he wasn't Prosecuting the
guy he wasn't going after him so we got
rid of him they bring in a new guy and
zlachevski returns so so the uh I think
it was London froze uh zlachevsky's
assets
Victor shulkin gets removed by Biden
zlachevsky immediately returns to
Ukraine to resume his work and then when
Trump gets in and starts poking around
zlachevski flees the country again so it
I I'm just I'm not going to believe this
argument that well we really wanted him
out when removing him actually helped
the guy that was supposedly the corrupt
guy in the first place it just doesn't
it doesn't make sense at all I I mean
you can you can come up you can say you
know Hunter Biden was working in Ukraine
it's corrupt he was feeding money back
to Joe Biden I mean you could say I'm
not even saying any of that but I mean I
mean people do right right but my point
is you've got a CIA director you've got
Hunter Biden CI director's name by the
way is Joseph kofer black he was on the
board right yeah they put him on the
board and so it's it's like look man
here I'll tell you what I think I don't
think in this instance uh that it's
overtly like Joe Biden's getting 10 for
the big guy with his son I think it's
that Europe didn't want to pay
exorbitant prices for natural gas but
Russia's got him by the balls the U.S
wanted to build a pipeline through Syria
on turkey called the cutter turkey
pipeline Syria said our Ally Russia
would be mad at us if we let you do that
so we won't surprise surprise we get
lucky and a civil war erupts in Syria
which is going to basically grant us
access Russia of course has their base
in Tartus creating all sorts of conflict
I think the U.S wants to get cheaper
energy into Europe they want to
strengthen the European Union with more
energy with with more Economic
Development because they want a stronger
block to compete with China in a certain
sense I'm not necessarily trusting all
of all of the elites I think I mean I
agree with you there I think that's
that's part of the U.S it's a plan yeah
right it's a big component and when
Syria was was not willing to abide by uh
these these you know these this offer I
suppose let's just call it convenient
that there's a massive destabilization
in the west is of course against Bashar
al-assad then when it comes to the fact
that gas prom runs I think 20 of natural
gas through Ukraine the U.S all of a
sudden has this interest in getting rid
of a corrupt prosecutor who happens to
have like 12 to 14 investigations into
the founder of an energy company where
Joe Biden's son and a CIA director are
currently on the board
I think the U.S is trying to gain
control of energy makes a lot of sense
Russia's competing with them they're
using Ukraine as a proxy I get it man
you know it's tough because I don't want
the US to falter I don't want China to
rise and take over and then we have
Chinese state communism but I also take
a look at Joe Biden flying Hunter to
China on Air Force 2 for private Equity
deals and I'm just like I don't trust
them at all on any of this yeah like I
mean I understand that and I definitely
think what you said is correct that the
US has a lot of interest in keeping the
US dollar value up because without it
being up we can lose ground to China and
our other adversaries but the whole like
you know I think their right is quick to
push us this Joe Biden Hunter Biden
corruption thing like the 10 for the big
guy that deal right that deal never took
place that deal never actually went
through and Joe was a private citizen at
the time who in his subsequent email
said I don't want anything to do with
this I mean so Joe also lied about his
involvement repeatedly yeah he lied he
well he either lied or he it things were
kind of uh I mean went over so he said
that he'd never talked to his son about
any of his business deals and then
there's him with his son and his buddies
that doesn't mean he had a business
conversation with him maybe he went to
bank accounts no I'm saying with this
with this guy no no I know but like yeah
they share a bank they and emails he
attacks and phone numbers so it's just
like come on man okay I mean but that's
all you can jump to these conclusions
that yeah since he said 10 for a big guy
he was doing other deals you know since
he got the since he said Shogun should
get fired it was because Hunter was
working for Prisma and maybe that's the
reason why you know there should be more
less
children of presidents working in other
countries I mean you could say there's
plenty of instances with Kushner and
Ivanka and I mean what about the the 666
Fifth Avenue deal in New York when
Kushner couldn't get anybody given
release and Qatar comes along right when
Saudi Arabia is blockading Qatar and
then Trump lifts the blockade as soon as
Kushner gets a
1.4 billion dollars so I mean but
there's no evidence that it's there are
two are linked but you could definitely
come up with ideas that there's
corruption going on right I mean I I
think the the issue is as it pertains to
Biden or Trump a fair point is yeah it's
always a pick your poison right Donald
Trump uh I don't know exactly how this
goes down and and again a lot of this
requires speculation but I think there's
a state department website advertising
Trump Doral or something like that I
don't know if you guys remember that no
there yeah it was like a state
department website was like stay at
Trump Resorts or something and and
people were like yo what the is going on
like you shouldn't be doing that Trump
wanted to have I think the G7 at Trump
derail in Florida oh yeah and then he
got back lash was like no I certainly
think you see a lot of this kind of
stuff but I think when it came to Donald
Trump
there was actually this despite much of
his shortcomings which I certainly think
there are many of Crossing into North
Korea that was really big for me
crossing the DMZ the Abraham Accords I
think were really really big I certainly
think they're questions I think anybody
who comes out and says that there's no
like that like Trump or any anybody who
who says like oh the bidens weren't
really doing this or the trumps weren't
really doing this I'm going to be like
dude everybody's always going to be
thinking about themselves to a certain
degree so my issue is after assessing
all the details I take a look at the
Biden family and Biden Inc as political
magazine called it I take a look at the
history of this guy his plagiarism and
the fortunes his families have tracked
along with his positions in government
and it's just like okay this guy is just
literally extracting from us Donald
Trump lost money becoming president like
his net worth has dropped he's lost
millions of dollars his tax returns
actually showed on paper right but you
don't know he could have foreign
business deals that are
being taxed in other countries his
social capital is off the off the charts
right now as well I mean a celebrity
yeah he made five million dollars at the
nfts there's amazing nfts yeah they were
really funny I mean Cowboy Trump get a
cowboy Trump get an astronaut did he get
one I did not get one I would not buy an
nft 100 bucks each is that what they 100
bucks each yeah and he sold them all
with them and that was like you know I
don't know man I think he dropped in the
predicted Market by like 10 cents when
he did that because it was like I
followed that too yeah I posted a
picture of one of his uh one of his
supporters riding in jail and him
looking through the cell be like hey you
guys want to buy something so uh I mean
talking about foreign policy here a
little bit there's corruption on both
sides I mean Jared Kushner was
negotiating better weapons deals for
Saudi Arabia all right that's a lot of
corruption there with with North Korea
John Bolton sabotaged any possibilities
of peace talks by comparing North Korea
saying that they're going into the
Libyan model of foreign policy but again
you could always compare the two but I I
think it's fair to say that
um the the Biden presidency has a lot
more room for corruption because he's a
career politician he's been in office he
knows everyone he knows all the
diplomats he knows all the bureaucrats
he has a lot more finagling room to do a
lot of really bad stuff and from the
beginning of his political career he has
been known as a man of the lobbyist he
has been giving a lot of special
interest groups a lot of what they
wanted uh specifically the military
industrial complex specifically big
Pharma specifically a lot of the bigger
agencies that are now coming in through
the bigger problems that he caused and
especially in Afghanistan China huge
winner out of all of that they're
gaining all the national resources uh
from Afghanistan with Ukraine BlackRock
is getting all the lucrative contracts
to rebuild that entire country after we
spent so much money bombing the crap out
of it uh and and causing so much chaos
um this is why I think it's important to
look at not just Trump but Biden but any
person in power in a very critical light
and criticize him to the highest degree
but do you guys agree or disagree with
me when it comes to saying get rid of
the lobbyists like yeah but but do you
guys agree that that Biden has more of a
more room to be corrupted than Trump who
hasn't been in politics that long I I
think that one of the appeals of trump
in 2016 was that he wasn't connecting a
lobbyists and I can see that as an
appeal but I don't know if that
necessarily means that he's not going to
be looking out for himself and his
businesses I I think owning a bunch of
businesses around the world and having
those businesses profit whether it's
financially or from from a standpoint of
getting name recognition for those
businesses I I think that that can lead
to just as much corruption
um so I I don't know I I think it's
definitely a problem in politics I think
that a lot of people in politics are
selfish and they're out for themselves
rather than out for the country I think
that money in politics is one of the
reasons it's like that I'd like to see
super Pacs go away and I'd like to see
money come out of politics
oh the whole the Trump Biden
conversation is like cat poop or dog
poop what do you want I'm like I'm not
hungry man this is why I don't like any
of them personally I'm like none of them
I don't want I don't want the dog crap I
don't want the poop one thing that
bothers me I view it that way I I I
disagree I I think Biden is like a moldy
sandwich where you're like I know it's
bad and you shouldn't eat it and Trump
is like well look man it's it's not the
healthiest thing in the world for you
but it's food I agree just Vice flip it
I would feel the same way yeah Biden's
got a track record of all this really
awful stuff and Trump's just a nasty guy
I I don't I don't know you look at the
economic numbers under Trump and it was
it was massive success up until covid
yeah but but then Biden took over after
covid and and has wages dropped
dramatically and inflation unemployment
rate is down inflation's finally
leveling up you're gonna have inflation
I mean the whole supply chain supply and
demand when supply chain gets cut off
because of all the covet stuff Supply
Falls the price goes up wait wait do you
guys think we have a positive economic
Outlook moving forward from here I'm
more positive right now than I was say
like three or four months ago I I think
that inflation's coming down I think a
lot relies on the fed and the fed's
gonna gonna keep raising rates until
they think inflation's kind of been
halted uh and and I think we're hitting
a point I think today's numbers were
decent uh the CPI numbers I I think
we're hitting a point where the fed's
going to start not raising as quickly
and I think that's positive I think we
could hit a mild recession sometime in
the next six or eight months But
ultimately I don't think we're bad
compared to the rest of the developed
world I think the United States is doing
quite quite remarkable compared to some
of these other countries I was just
going to say
actually I forget what I was going to
say I was going to say the markets rig
the numbers are rigged and if you go to
the supermarket inflation is not
stagnating it is hitting hard a lot of
Americans and a lot of people are
dealing with record high energy prices
record high food prices and the real
inflation that the average American
deals with especially in the poor and
middle class is absolutely astronomical
compared to everyone else well I just
want to say inflation from November to
December has stagnated according to CPI
data so I believe it was it went up what
was it point three percent but when you
take out oil and uh volatile Foods it's
actually down I think 0.1 percent so
it's actually in deflationary we'll take
those out not necessarily it still means
the year on year record is like you're
in Europe can't can't fall unless we
have deflation it can't fall
significantly unless we have deflation
which would be bad for the economy so
let me ask you do you uh how would you
I'm gonna ask you this question how do
you rate the condition of the national
economy right now very bad fairly bad
fairly good or very good some where
between fairly good and and what was the
second one slightly better fairly bad
yeah I'd say the same so according to
Civics right now with 808 000 responses
over the past eight years if you take a
look at the latest developments from
May of last year 50 reported very bad
currently 40 percent say very bad 28 say
fairly bad 26 percent say fairly good
two percent say very good only two
percent say very good now what do you
think is going to happen if I sort this
by political affiliation
I think we all know I think everybody
knows so I'll start with independent
among independent voters 44 say very bad
30 say fairly bad and 20 say fairly good
so it's actually worse than all combined
now Republican I think is obvious there
we go 70 says very bad 25 fairly bad
among Democrats 50 say fairly good now
how can that be that that to me makes
absolutely no sense when we're looking
at seven dollar cabbage and nine dollar
eggs yeah no I don't believe it I I
agree I I think inflation's horrible I
think inflation has definitely impacted
things I I think that it was unavoidable
given not not just Biden's stimulus and
when he came into office I did like a
1.2 trillion dollar semias Trump gave
three trillion in stimulus or something
like that and as he headed out the door
uh and it's the fed the FED kept rates
low for 20 years that's just adding
adding all of this excess demand to the
economy and now they have to pull back
and when they pull back it's going to
cost us jobs so I I think that yes
inflation's bad I think if you take the
United States economy compare it to
Europe to Japan uh to China even I I
think we're doing remarkably better and
I think that's you got to compare it
because the situation we're in after
covid I think it the lockdowns affected
things the supply chain disrupt
disruptions affected things oil shocks
from Russia that affected things I I
think that overall we're doing decent
compared to the rest of the world I'm
very good at compared to the best I do
think people uh need to recognize Donald
Trump was the president when we were
doing a lot of this inflationary policy
stuff during covet like a lot of the
stimulus stuff that was going but like I
don't blame him I I think I think I
think Biden's last stimulus was probably
too much but also at the time I don't
think we realized that covert was going
to subside we're going to get Omicron
and you know it wasn't going to be as
bad of a strain and things started
coming back a lot faster than we
expected I think going back I would say
he shouldn't have done that last
stimulus I think that probably would
have helped inflation somewhat I don't
think I honestly don't think it would
have done more than maybe half a half a
percentage Point were you guys in favor
of Donald Trump giving out two thousand
dollar checks yeah
was that that was a policy you guys
agreed with I didn't I was like what are
you doing are you crazy yeah probably
like a Ubi personally myself based on my
principles and values I was like I was
like that's that's a little bit too much
for me and I think just spending money
and printing money out of thin air has
brought us to this very irresponsible
place where we are what 34 trillion
dollars in debt yeah that's not
something that's feasible that's not
something we could get out of that's
something that ours children children
children
will be paying for if we're lucky if the
whole system doesn't crash because we
have essentially allowed some of the
richest people in the world to enrich
themselves while of course everyone else
was screwed over and when we look at you
know the covered years through the Trump
years he has allowed the largest
transfer of wealth in recorded human
history that to me is atrocious that to
me is absolutely unacceptable he gave us
two thousand dollars but the billionaire
class they got way more than that so
that's why I was against it on principle
I I mean what would have happened though
if
he didn't if Trump didn't issue that
stimulus that Biden didn't issue his
stimulus
what would have happened would the
economy have fallen so low that you know
we could have hit a depression we don't
know we you know economics is that's
what's kind of fun about economics is
that
everybody has different theories of what
would happen and you don't know until it
actually does happen you make a very
good point here but there's a lot of
economists who are making the term the
the theory that if you prolong a
depression or a recession it's going to
hit a lot harder and I think our
financial policy has been prolonging are
we any kind of Correction and now
because of these fiscally irresponsible
policies when there is a correction it's
going to be hard and it's going to be
bad and it's going to wipe out people
instead of having the natural flow of
the economy like there used to be up and
down rates going up and down so this
this is this is going to conflate into a
huge problem that's going to absolutely
hurt so many people and that's why I'm
against it I think it's good that rates
are going up now because you need that
in your toolbox for when we do hit it
you know an epic disaster it would have
been good to have that tool when covet
hit so that we didn't need to have as
much money being pumped in through
fiscal policy we could use monetary
policy but we didn't have that tool
unless we went to negative rates which
you know I don't think anybody's
supporting negative actually Trump
supported negative rates at the time
he's kind of pushing for this dead but
but no I I do think that that we're
headed towards a cliff at some point
whether it's in three years or 30 years
I don't know when that's going to be but
I it's obviously not sustainable to have
this debt and something needs to be done
I think we can all agree agree to that
yes it's not monetary it's not mm not
modern monetary policy is prescribed by
the definition of the term which is you
print massive amounts of money and then
you invested in infrastructure to
rebuild Capital so that it overcomes
your debt this is they just printed
massive amounts of money and put it in
people's bank accounts there's no
industry being created with it so it's
not modern monetary policy yeah the
Federal Reserve went to Blackrock it's
like here have all this money went to
the stock market you're losing money
here have all this money that was
American foreign fiscal policy it's
crazy I think it's also from the bottom
it's a different Theory do you start
from the bottom and go up or do you
start from top and go down and the two
different foods of thought on that you
know some people think it's better to
start at the bottom some people think
it's better you start at the top and you
know I don't know there's an answer that
every situation is different I think if
you could go either direction top or
bottom but as long as there's industry
being created like if the money's being
spent on groceries it's not moderate
it's not monetarily fiscally possible
it's just pure debt that people eat get
fat then they but here here's one of the
issues I have with uh the fat giving all
this money to Blackrock and these and
these big companies is ESG are you guys
familiar with ESG so it's environmental
for those unfamiliar environmental
social governance it's basically
ideological uh I I think it's basically
state state communism or state
capitalism whatever you want to call it
injected into corporations imposing an
ideological bent on what they can or
can't do in exchange for a score it's
like social credit score what do you
guys think about ESG you know like like
I think there's
I'm typically against the government
getting involved in corporations uh but
I I also see where some people are
coming from I I think that that Enviro
that our environment's important I have
young kids I hope that climate change
doesn't progress like some people are
projecting uh I I I think it's it's kind
of one of those gray areas like I don't
think it's ESG should be totally cut off
but I also don't think that that
we should take it over and and and
Overkill I I think they don't remove it
everything has an inputing I think but
ESG it's either in our institutions or
it's not right either we're telling uh
uh so this is what happened in West
Virginia there is energy companies in
West Virginia it's a big industry and
they these companies were told they
could no longer secure financing to
operate because it was against ESG and
it's like okay well that destroys the
economy of West Virginia and puts
everybody out of work now I'm not going
to sit here and be like we should burn
the country burn the plant to the ground
for the sake of someone having a job but
certainly the solution isn't just to be
alike we've implemented an ideological
system that now destroys your industry
there's got to be ways to to get you
know we've got to find a way to I think
technologically Advance away from this I
agree so like the the example I often
give is how they used to be scared that
New York would be littered with mounds
of horse crap everywhere because the
horses were transporting all the goods
and there was like this order article
written like a turn of the century 1900s
there will be so much horse crap you'll
be able to live in the city anymore and
they invented the car yeah and so my
view is like we need to slowly shift off
these industry through invention and
Innovation ESG seems more like what
China does the government gets involved
or some kind of ideological entity gets
involved and then punishes people takes
away their ability to operate their
business unless they do things like fire
their white board member and put up
black women as a board member I don't
see how that's actually solving any
problems or making anyone's life better
other than actually creating racial
animosity destroying Industries and and
my view actually is if they start
destroying these these companies they're
actually going to make the issue of
pollution worse it's going to result in
people with like disheveled broken down
disgusting houses an inability to
properly maintain a building meaning
you're going to get medals leeching into
the water people are going to get sickly
it's going to create pollution problems
the economy isn't just can we build a
house it's can we properly remove waste
recycle wastes innovate ways to solve
these problems and destroying these
industries in my opinion will probably
result in us just piling up waste and
living in filth and then you're going to
get people who are going to be angry
about the race stuff so
that that's that's where it comes to you
know the financial policy of giving
money to these big corporations like
like black recorder to buy a property
it's the ideological component I suppose
outside of all of that though we can
talk for a bit I'm curious your thoughts
on wokeness in general critical race
Theory we should talk about all that
stuff
yeah I I I think that those in the right
pay too much attention to to the social
issues and things that really aren't
impacting them
and if they're doing so
in a way that affects the happiness of
other people and affects the way other
people feel I I don't I don't agree with
it I I think that politicians on the
right and not everybody I I think that
they should focus on other issues rather
than some of the issues they've been
focusing on whether whether it is the
LGBT community all that stuff and I I do
have a particularly what's your
definition of woke like like that's
something I like I don't know really
what the definition of woke is that's
interesting so if you uh it's it's if
you go back in time it I'll I'll
simplify this thing I I know what the
what the general definition of woke is
and it has to do with inequality and
stuff like that but is that how the
right generally refers to I think I
think so so when you think you're
enlightened but you're not kind of well
perhaps it's uh the simple definition
colloquially for the right is an
ideological cult with no clear aims or
goals masquerading as a social justice
movement is one simple way to define
that the harder way to break it down is
going back in time the culture war
starts with intersectional feminism
which is elements of wokeness you you it
then evolves into the greater critical
race Theory which then starts adopting
elements of critical gender Theory and
now has become this big amalgam of all
of these
I I they're not necessarily all Marxist
derivatives but they're but into a
certain degree they are and the way I
see it
if I was going to Define it to uh if I
was talking to somebody who already
understood and agreed with me I Define
it as fire something that's just
consuming and destroying and eventually
will wipe us all out it's it's not so
simple to be like it's just something
that makes someone happy no it's quite
literally like they they say that um the
simple example and they're all grains of
sandwich you can't say woman it's
offensive it's not inclusive so you need
to say women with a why because women
are not men then they say actually
that's offensive you should say we make
sin with an ax because that includes
this and I say woman so I mean but you
know my point is like you end up with
issues where people are getting banned
from Twitter because they said okay dude
and this person is no longer is there
actually an example
zubi got suspended the person identified
as something and he wasn't misgendering
he was having an argument and they said
something went okay dude like he was
just yeah I mean I think that's too far
I think but this has been too far for 10
years and it's getting to the point now
where you know it starts with saying
things like hey you know we shouldn't be
censoring people because they have these
opinions and then it leads us to Hunter
Biden's laptop is leaked it's got
damning videos and and information that
implicates Joe and Hunter Biden whether
they're guilty or not implicates and
multiple polls have come out showing
that if the American public had been
made aware of the information on that
laptop I think it's between six and
seven percent said they would not have
voted for Joe Biden theoretically that
that would mean that Donald Trump was
president now that's massive and so that
means that all of these issues we've
been concerned about with the the hate
speech rhetoric which is like the idea
that we should ban hate speech is all
the component of wokeness Twitter then
implements policies based on this
Twitter then uses that for political
advantages and now we know for a fact
that for the most part it was Democrats
leaning on Twitter for favors
Republicans did some sometimes as well
but because the Twitter staff was
overwhelmingly San Francisco liberals
Democrats were and and in government too
like the bite Administration actively
are using the private sector as a weapon
against their political opponents and
what we view as wokeness is now just
like you can say woke or you say red
pills you can say left or right we're
seeing a total bifurcation of of our
culture so the interesting thing is
I've always been fairly liberal in the
lit in the literal traditional liberal
sense growing up in a Democrat City and
then the issue of free speech arises I
look at these stories notably from
Gizmodo and it says uh you know Facebook
employees were routinely Banning
conservative news outlets from their
trending tab as 2016 they reported that
and I said hey guys you see the story
what happens whole bunch of leftist
organizations come out saying Tim Poole
is a conspiracy theorist who thinks the
right is being persecuted because I
literally cited a a left-wing news
source they actually included in my
Wikipedia as if it was some kind of
smear that I agree with conservatives
that they're more likely to be
suppressed or censored when it's a fact
and it's always been a fact and this is
the component of the culture war that
leaves people on the left calling me
right wing or something so it's like if
I were to want if I if I was going to
vote for someone who is you know
Democrat or Progressive because I was a
big fan of Bernie before I think he lost
his mind it's not going to happen when
the Liberals and the Democrats are
actively supporting a chaotic ideology
of Destruction and seeking to censor
ideas they don't like yeah like I I
think
you have a point in some respect but I
think most Democrats most liberals are
not woke as you say I think what the
right does is they jump over and jump
onto instances that took place and paint
the picture that Liberals are all woke
or Liberals are all you know you have to
say woman with a y or whatever you said
it was just like how a lot on the left
say Republicans are all racist or
Republicans are all anti-semitic like I
think that's I think there's
similarities there but I agree but I I
agree that there's similarities but I
think obviously one side's wrong right
obviously the right is not all
anti-semitic that's ridiculous but you
can say that the left is not entirely
awoke I would agree that Liberals are
not all completely woke but they
certainly agree with all of it now I
know I've heard the same thing they make
they say not all Donald Trump supporters
are racist but all racists are Trump
supporters then they say that the people
who support Trump are the you know
blindly supporting white supremacy
another nonsense and it's just not true
Donald Trump did not not defend
neo-nazis as very fine people that was a
complete lie they made the whole thing
up Donald Trump literally said they
should be condemned totally that's a
quote and they lie but when it comes to
liberals on the left in wokeness I'll
give you one example the parental rights
and education bill in Florida
so you you get uh kids who are severely
depressed and being abused by their
teachers the parents then find out
because probably because I think a lot
of it was because of the remote learning
parents had no idea their kids were
suffering and depressed and the parents
the schools weren't telling them and the
schools were actually trying to get
these kids to undergo Medical Treatments
without the parents knowledge parents
get mad so the Republicans in Florida
say we're gonna do a bill if you're
third grade or below no sex education
afterwards the parents have a right to
know about sex education what happens
the Democrats come out with this big lie
don't say gay completely not true
because the bill barged you from saying
straight as well as saying gay but they
run this fabricated narrative to smear
anybody who says parents have a right to
know what's going on with their kids
that's wokeness now whether all
Democrats know they're part of a cult or
are just blindly following it is the
question so that bill I actually follow
that bill closely because I live in
Florida and I have my wife's brother is
gay so I'm I'm close with him so I
followed the bill and it it it changed
it evolved that bill evolved a lot and
so so at the end I don't think it's as
close to don't say gay anymore I don't I
don't think it really said that at
toward the end of the bill so so what
what I'm saying is that
I I understand
those who are angry I I cease both sides
there I can see both sides on that bill
I I think you know the whole idea that
you can't so the way you understand it
do you say say a child has two fathers
draws a picture of his two fathers
and another kid says what's that you got
two dads and starts making fun of the
kid and the teacher comes in and says
you know some families there's two men
in the family they love each other and
they can have a perfectly fine family is
is the bill doesn't buy that yeah but
it's kind of hard to understand that and
I think that's why a lot of people
especially early on teachers were
worried hey if I say this am I going to
get sued am I going to have to but it
was it was specifically outlined that
only in classroom instruction was it
prohibited yeah
it was all it was all defined right so
quite literally and this was actually
outlined by the politicians a teacher
could walk up to a group of say it's
recess the teacher could walk up to a
group of students and say I'm a man
married to a man this means this that
otherwise it just couldn't be part of
the curriculum I don't think that's how
I always were at least not early on
early on in the bill the way I read it
it was like you couldn't talk about it
when it goes to passing yeah and we're
at the point where it's like this is
what's actually happening the narrative
of across the country was all these
celebrities went gay
but even the bill itself like initially
you couldn't say straight either it was
just no sex ed period for third grade or
below so like if a kid drew a picture of
a man and a woman and someone made fun
of them or theoretically the argument
was still you'd be like that's a
question for your parents Yeah but
whether it's a man or woman a man and
man or a woman do you guys think third
graders and Below should learn about sex
ed no I don't think that but I think a
lot of this was a big misunderstanding
and a lot of people kind of jumped to
conclusions and speculated when when
they really didn't know so I think you
know the more clarifications but to have
a whole National outcry kind of push
this larger narrative which wasn't
really true only empowered people like
DeSantis I'm definitely going to go back
and read the final bill because I I know
I was following it really closely but
then so talk about wokeness then
DeSantis goes and takes the special tax
exemption from Disney because they were
against the bill so like isn't that kind
of the same thing being woke like you're
attacking a private company because they
don't agree with your political
philosophy I mean that that approaches
an authoritarianism I I disagree I think
Disney shouldn't have had the special
Provisions in the first place
an aside no the fact that the state gave
a major corporation oh yeah
I agree they shouldn't have had in the
first place but they're taking it should
have done that a long time ago for any
reason it was as if it I believe it was
because so you guys believe corporations
shouldn't pay any taxes is that way yeah
right no but it seemed like it was it
was the Retro corporations be allowed to
Lobby their employees and and the state
to prevent legislation I I don't
necessarily think so but but I I think
that the fact that he used that as the
reason why he took it he was punishing
them for being against him that's how at
least it appeared don't you think that's
why he did it he didn't just say oh now
is a good time because randomly it was
awful opinion argument I mean yeah I
could argue it's because they're
advancing abuse of children and it was
deeply unpopular in the state and they
shouldn't have been giving special
privileges in the first place so now's
the best time to remove it from them
yeah but I feel like laws should take
care of that not a governor you know
stepping in and saying because you go
but it wasn't my policy it was it was
the legislator that actually had to pass
it yeah but I I'm mean that bills yeah
the bill but they're against that law
they can no no that's their freedom of
speech the stripping Disney of their
provision came from the legislature yeah
Ron DeSantis was just yeah and did he
sign off on it I assume I I can't
remember exactly what happened I think
they ended up losing that in the long
run like I think Disney went to court
and ended up winning but I I think that
this is a tough one because I can
certainly agree you know we have to find
that balance like we don't want the
government to to attack private entities
because of their like if finding that
balance is difficult I don't want power
to centralize in in the government or
corporations we got to find that I will
say outside of it Disney shouldn't have
had that I think we agreed Disney should
be allowed to build the nuclear power
plant that's so weird I think the issue
is that it helped the Florida economy so
much that that it was Florida saw it as
hey we're going to do this but we're
going to get so much back in tax revenue
I mean how much how much money are they
making from from tourists coming to
Orlando every year I think the uh the
other issue is it's not just in Florida
right when it comes to the weakness
right so so going back to the root issue
we're talking about wokeness you're
saying you know not all Liberals are
awoke but I think all liberals March
behind the woke blindly so you know one
thing we've referenced quite a bit is
this book genderqueer that we have here
without getting into this for the 800th
time for everyone who's listening you've
got places like Loudoun County which is
literally 30 seconds away from where we
are right now you drive 30 seconds boom
you're in Loudoun County and there was a
student at a school who I think he raped
two girls is that what happened it was
the the trans student at least two girls
in the bathroom and then the prince
and then when the parents started
complaining about this stuff they get
shut down they get called far right the
Biden Administration investigates them
as terrorists and the parents speaking
out about this was arrested and
manhandled by police officers when it
was his daughter that got you know uh
raped so you know those visuals were
absolutely insane and crazy seeing a
father saying hey this is happening and
him being shut down and arrested and
taken away which was crazy but so so
this is what leads ultimately to you
know young kid winning they said they
say that the parents were getting fed up
with the wokeness
it's not just uh genderqueer we had
astronomani came on with a stack of
books that are appearing in public
schools for children and it is let I'll
put it this way let me ask you a
question uh are you guys religious at
all I I'm Jewish but I I probably
describe myself as agnostic all right uh
are you similar yeah do you think let me
give you an example if there was a grade
school first graders and they had a math
book and it had a math problem and it
said there are 50 sinners in Sodom and
50 sinners in Gomorrah and Abraham
speaks to God and says will you spare
this if there is you know 10 righteous
people how many righteous people would
have to be you know how many people
would be remaining in Sodom and gomorph
10 righteous people were removed do you
want me to answer that do you think that
would be an appropriate math question in
a public school yeah but because it's
religion right because it's teaching the
story of lot Abraham Sodom and more
that's what they're doing in schools
right now with critical race Theory
which is an ideology see that that's
another thing where I think
you have to say there's no solid line
there but so so look go ahead the math
problem we actually pulled the book up
and it says Jamal is stopped by the
police 17 times on his way home from
school while Eric has stopped three
times what percentage of the time has
was Jamal being stopped and it shows a
picture of a little black boy a cop an
angry cop pointing at the little black
boy that's racial that is critical race
Theory ideology being weaseld into math
problems to instill in ideology in
children I don't I don't think it's
appropriate but but there's this
difference between separation of church
and state and something like that so I
mean I disagree but I mean technically
you're not supposed to I mean the
Constitution you know and critical race
theories of religion it's a non-theistic
religion I shouldn't say critical race
Theory but um wokeness as we describe it
as an umbrella term is a non-theistic
religion it follows all the tenets of
religion except for a deity I say that
about so much stuff though like like if
you start you could say Trump supporting
is a religion you could say you know
Bitcoin maximalist that's a religion
Cults every cult you could it kind of is
Charlie occult yes I agree like so but I
mean there are elements of trump
supporters I call cultists 100 yeah yeah
but I mean if you start saying that's a
religion but there's no there's no
trumpism Matt Gates challenges McCarthy
Trump calls him out and Matt Gates
responds with sad actually just
rejecting Trump outright many of these
the these Republicans are just telling
Trump no there are there are a lot of uh
yeah but it didn't happen back then when
he was president you know to a certain
degree I would say I agree with you but
I will also point this out you are like
the fourth people we would describe as
being left lane who have ever been
willing to come on the show because they
will not have conversations the right is
willing to have a conversation where
there's disagreement dispute and
potentially proving them wrong you know
I would take issue that because you're
left leaning I'm left leaning we're both
libertarian left-leaning I think it is
the that what happens is NPCs will
follow blindly any kind of ideology
it might even be considered like a
political philosophy so I don't I I'm
all about teaching kids about communism
this is what that is but when you teach
them to become Communists you're
indoctrinating and so the concern is are
they indoctrinating children with
philosophy in school like see my issue
is where what is the clear line of
critical race theory if you teach about
MLK is that no like so but where is that
look what what differentiates that from
like where does that line end there has
to be a clear line there is critical
race theory is defined as the concept of
the oppressed versus oppressor on racial
grounds of the white man as the
oppressor and the non-whites as the
oppressed so in history though that took
place so when you teach history about
China or Japan I mean in America sure
but like so if you teach American
history is that critical race Theory no
okay so so here's the issue Kimberly
Crenshaw wrote in her book it was it was
it was an essay I believe multiple
people contributed that Karl Marx got
one thing he got something right with
critical theory that there is an
oppressed and oppressor class Marx wrote
that it was the wealthy who are the
oppressors and the poor who were the
oppressed I'm simplifying it and she
said he doesn't understand the racial
component of America so we need a
critical race Theory and that's how they
coined the term the idea then is white
people are inherently oppressors no
matter what and non-white people are
inherently oppressed no matter what that
means Oprah Winfrey is oppressed and a
homeless veteran sleeping in the gutter
is an oppressor and that's psychotic in
my opinion but that is the basis for the
ideology they teach in these schools so
when they did the uh the whiteness
contract what was that what was that
book it was called your mother you want
to look that one up yeah again Oscar
nomani brings this book to us and it
shows a whiteness contract with a devil
tail and a hand reaching out and it says
sign the contract and you'll receive all
of these benefits at the expense of your
non-white friends that is indoctrinating
kids with an ideology when you think you
mentioned separation of church and state
and I find this fascinating because what
does church and state really mean
religions are ideologies they believe in
tenets they believe in a certain set of
Faith faith-based you know ideas and
then they hold true ideology
what's the difference between that and
any other ideology obviously religions
have some spiritual component to them
but if we're talking about separation of
church and state what we're really
talking about is separation of an
individual's ideology and the state the
law should govern fairly and equally
based upon certain facts the
Constitution and human rights not
whether someone believes someone is
inherently evil or an oppressor or
someone is going to heaven or hell yeah
but ideologies are just
opinions ideologies are just opinions to
another level so that the problem is
liberal you ban creationism from schools
because it was masquerade it was
Christianity masquerading as science
then I argue the same thing for critical
race Theory so so this is the way
liberals tend to view critical race
Theory they view it from the standpoint
that
black people were oppressed by white
people and you can't teach
that that took place that's a lie but
but
but the problem is
certain people view it that way and if
the bill if a bill is written saying you
can't talk about critical race Theory
what if somebody says that's critical
race Theory then that teacher is going
to get thrown out of school teacher is
going to be prosecuted perhaps well
you're talking about an issue for for a
judge yeah but what our teachers are
paid in Florida they're paid like thirty
thousand dollars a year because look
you're making an argument that like what
what if someone's argument if that bill
is written exactly how you explain it
then I think that'll be a build you
support but if the bill just says
critical race Theory it is just two the
law usually defines terms yeah but I
haven't seen a law that did find it the
way you've defined that's the literal
definition of what it is yeah well so so
then you extend it and from the book and
what if you have a class that's talking
about income inequalities and and you
link that certain races might have be in
in equal to others because of so the
Title IX violation no no so so so you
have it you have a you have a class that
might say seven sorry
so what I'm saying is what it what if
you're teaching that that a certain area
of of this state is uh
socio-economically unequal to this area
and
a percentage of this this area is also
80
African-American I mean like how far
where do you draw that line is is that
now going to say that what's that like I
can say whatever you saying that that's
going to be considered critical race
there because it's it's going back to
race and socioeconomical differences
what if a school board says it is
critical race theory that teacher gets
[ __ ] you're making you're making an
argument for the for the courts to
interpret the law that's no one is
arguing that people should be able to
misinterpret the law reports haven't
interpreted that law and it's so broad
that but one judge a judge in Florida
judging Georgia a judge in New York's
gonna New York just said bomb stock ban
was unconstitutional so you have one
Federal jurisdiction saying one thing a
matter for the courts is not a matter
for argument in law I'm saying outright
there should be a separation from
ideology and and and and the state we
should govern this country based on what
we
vote in so for instance I mentioned
title title seven Title Nine is sex
title seven is race it is a Title VII
violation for what Joe Biden is doing
right now in the federal government is
completely illegal it's illegal and
Donald Trump banned that and Biden
removed that ban what's that what are
you referring to in Government
Contracting Donald Trump made it illegal
to claim white people are bad or evil
and to implement trainings based on race
this is directly in line with the 1964
Civil Rights Act this is Title VII this
is uh 1991 blah blah blah amended cetera
et cetera you cannot in this country go
before a group of children employees
government workers period and say One
race is better than the other that's our
training but that's what they're doing
but they're they're saying One race is
better than another yes One race is
equal to another no they're saying
they're like is there an example of this
of the actual thing an actual statement
somebody made there was uh I'd have to
pull up Christopher rufo's article
because we haven't we haven't pulled it
up in a long time
let me see if we can find it no I agree
I mean if they're going around saying
saying One race is better than the other
yeah I don't think that's that's
National nuclear Labs employees sent a
seminar that claimed rugged
individualism and hard work are white
male culture there's also the
Smithsonian Museum that said working
hard and being on time are elements of
white people like as if to imply look
outside of any argument you want to make
against like Asians Hispanics or I'm
sorry uh black people or Hispanics
whatever the craziest thing is when the
woke people and the critical race
theorists argue this right here nuts
Sandia Labs telling people that hard
work is white male culture as if black
people don't work hard that's insane but
then when I have conversations with
these people they say oh you know it's
white people who who adhere to schedules
and it's white people who who save for
the future not kidding that's in the
Smithsonian and then I'm like what about
Asians they plan longer for the future
on average than than white people do
this is an insanely racist ideology that
does not belong in government
one of the reasons why I was more
inclined to support Donald Trump because
Joe Biden is actively supporting what is
overtly illegal like let me ask you do
you think I mean Trump did too and how
many executive orders were overturned by
judges during Trump's presidency I'm
referring specifically to critical race
Theory Title IX Title VII Etc so like
let me ask you guys if a teacher told a
group of students that one race was bad
and One race was not should that be
allowed no but that's what they're doing
okay and I mean that teacher should be
fired but this is critical race Theory I
mean but shouldn't that teacher be fired
anyway like I mean do you need a bill
that says you can't teach critical race
Theory so all the lines get blurred and
teachers have less to less motive to be
teachers I don't know who this guy is
who's holding up this book but I chose
this for a reason whiteness is a bad
deal it always was dude we can see your
pointy tail and a white hand with a
whiteness contract with fire and money
and Devil's tale and and uh
goat feet is sticking out so this book
is in the Great Schools all over the
place that might be called not my idea
not my idea right and here's the issue
when someone like me comes out and I'm
like Urban skateboarding liberal dude
and I say yo that's messed up you know
what happens all the Democrats say I'm
I'm lying I'm wrong and I'm a
conservative
so okay so so I I totally agree with you
I I don't think that belongs in schools
but at the same time it I feel that the
bill this critical race there I think is
an overreaction to a very few cases of
this like discipline the teacher fire
the teacher you don't have to write a
bill that's not then going to be vaguely
misunderstood by who knows around the
around the country and
puts teachers in difficult situations of
should can I be saying this should I be
saying this can I be teaching this like
do you know how severe the teacher
shortages especially in Florida like my
son doesn't even have a kindergarten
teacher he doesn't have a teacher
because I mean I think people don't want
to teach her completely corrupt as it is
Pledge Your Allegiance to this country
before you say that again don't you
remember the indoctrination Camp Pledge
Your Allegiance another day but now
they're something a lot of these schools
are doing pledge allegiance to the pride
flag
you know about the history of public
schools Luke who was it was it
Rockefeller well Rockefeller was a key
instrumental figure with his uh larger
institutions when it came to building up
this model of essentially uh building up
good slave Factory workers a lot of the
education system depending on what time
they start the breaks that they have is
all based on the bell ringing creating
them to be good Factory workers there's
there's a lot of consensus here but
there's also a lot of crazy things
especially with the New York City public
school board system even having one of
their representatives previously a
couple years publicly declare that hey
if there's a poor white kid we have to
spend resources on a rich black kid over
a poor white kid because this is to
fight all the racism that's happening in
this country when we see Educators and
people that have been entrusted in our
education system giving out resources
based on color and not on need that to
me is is something that we have a big
problem with and should be kind of
corrected in my opinion I I mean that
goes to Hope reparation argument and you
know I had a class in college about
inequality and I you know there's good
art I feel there's good arguments on
both sides of that and if I'm a if I'm a
black person I've seen you know my
family struggle all their the
generations struggling you just want be
like just give one of us an opportunity
and we'll try and make a difference so I
I see their point of view but I also can
see that poor white family's view that
could also be stuck in a similar
situation maybe not dating back to
slavery you know maybe it's not they
never got started maybe it's something
else bad happened there family maybe
their father was killed and their mother
had to raise them so do you agree giving
more resources to Rich black kids over
poor white kids because of their race in
general like like if there's if there's
you know I think it would be based on a
situation like I would think I'd need
the details on both situations do you
are you guys in favor of reparations
based on slavery I'm
indifferent like like not indifferent
but I I see both sides both both I'm
glad I don't have to make that decision
I'm and you know like that would I don't
think that would be a
a factor in me voting for one candidate
or other just because I I see the
difficulty in that decision do you think
race should be taken into account when
someone applies to college
I I think so I I really do I I think
that that they need to try and kind of
even even out the the racial why you
think people are different based on race
like I I don't think they're different
but I think they have different
socio-economic upbringings I think that
one race is has been pushed down for
generations and generations and the
Polish people right the Polish people
have been screwed over historically
Jewish people too no no so would you be
willing to go to say a an impoverished
seven-year-old Asian boy look him in the
eyes and say you are not welcome at
Harvard because you look too much like
those I I get totally get that argument
and and and I do think it's difficult I
like maybe it makes more sense to be
like where you where you live and not
your race it would make more sense to
say hey yeah where where you live or
what your background your lineage your
lineage your lineage but how do you go
about that you know because like I agree
it's on it's unfair for some people
Harvard you know they have that lawsuit
where it's you have to score 1300 if
you're Asian a thousand if you're white
800 if you're Latino and like 700 if
you're black which I just think is
extremely racist but they're doing it
because they think they want they want
racial parity which to me also makes no
sense as if to imply that race is the
component by which we measure humanity
and it's a weird thing to me but that
means that poor Asians will be kicked
out for Rich black kids
and I'm just like I don't I don't know I
don't know I I understand the argument
and and I I can understand both sides of
it so I don't understand their argument
at all like what's their argument I
think the argument is that we as a
nation have pushed down this group of
people African-Americans for so long
generation after generation going back
to the 1800s
I think we owe it to them in a way to
equalize their opportunity now
but actually I see something real quick
sorry I I see it I see my view is based
on we're all Americans and your views
based on we're white and you're black
my view is that they that we've we as a
nation have pushed these people down for
for so long that that right these people
not us you see what I'm saying so so
like I view us all as one group
let me try it I think go ahead so I
don't want to speak as a black person
because I don't know you know I don't
know their life and I don't know
everything they've gone through but from
my point of view the way that I would
view it if I can imagine myself in their
situation which I know I can't fully is
my great great great grandfather was a
slave
he had to he worked for this man he got
nothing
uh you know he had his son pause it real
quick yeah not even that far back okay
we've got people like whose grandparents
okay so the older people all right great
great grandfather that would help no
literal like my grandfather okay I'll do
my grandfather my grandfather was a
slave and you know he couldn't he had to
work his ass off
didn't earn a dime you know and then his
owner died he died and my father was his
son and he tried making a life for
himself but
he he had to go to an all-black school
with teachers who were subpar and he
ride the back on the back of the bus he
didn't he had his education just wasn't
there it wasn't on par with these white
people
so he didn't get a good education he had
to work in the factory uh you know
work he worked his butt off and hardly
earned a dime and he I couldn't go to
college because of it because you know I
had to go work from an early age and
then my son I want him to get an
education but I can't afford to pay his
college I you know he's smart but he's
not as smart as this guy because I
couldn't spend as much time raising him
as some of these other fathers so I want
him to have the same opportunity as his
white counterparts so that's the point
of view from the black person so I can
see why they get so why they feel so
impacted by what happened in the past I
want to clarify too what I mean to say
is there are people in this country who
are older who's actually like very old
and their grandparents we I was watching
some video about it but then for the
people that we've talked to it's great
grandparents yeah stuff like that but uh
here the issue I take with it is we had
one conversation so what about the um
what about the dude whose family has
been historically poor because his
great-great-grandfather died fighting
for the union to end slavery and they
lost everything their house was burned
down and destroyed by the Confederates
and now their slack-jawed you know
Mountain trailer people they are not
entitled to anything and they they have
they have a right to feel entitled to
stuff too but they're not going to get
it because you're basing everything on
Race I mean you I mean like the system
would be like it would say oh black
people are oppressed therefore black
people the issue I take with that is
Oprah Winfrey does not deserve a handout
she doesn't need it she's one of the
wealthiest people on the planet and
these people who are in rural West
Virginia which was which broke off from
Virginia to stay with the union and
actually ended up opposing slavery these
people are impoverished impoverished
because of that history shouldn't they
get some kind of reparation for the
sacrifices maybe they should yeah maybe
they should but then it's not race you
see yeah but or what about the British
Sailors that were fighting in Africa
against slavery no so what I'm saying is
that these
this group of individuals who it dates
back to slavery so these people most
black Americans have ancestors who were
enslaved so they feel like they deserve
some sort of you know
something to help them rise to the level
of their counterparts is that true I
mean it would be very hard to kind of
calculate I think most black Americans
are descendant of slaves I've heard data
suggesting the opposite of that really
because there's been a lot of
immigration there's been a lot of people
coming in but it's going to be very hard
to tell because how do you prove a lot
of this stuff when there wasn't really a
lot of records as well no I and I've
talked about this quite a bit too
especially the documentary I did in
Ferguson and St Louis absolutely there
are people who are the descendants of
slaves so they have no generational
wealth and then there's a tendency among
white people to have generational wealth
but the solution in my opinion isn't
race based it is not critical race
Theory because what ends up happening is
then when you say that white people are
oppressors and non-whites are oppressed
there's like a homeless veteran who grew
up in the sticks low-income family joins
the military fights for this country
comes home is injured in a wheelchair
he's an oppressor like come on man
that's a crooked idea geology that makes
no sense I want to call and that like
Will Smith's kids are going to get you
know benefits yeah I mean I'm not saying
that white people are oppressors I mean
back then they were impressors during
times of slavery the majority of white
people were who owned slaves obviously
were oppressors right but I think that's
an interesting question too what does it
mean to be an oppressor yeah if you're
getting your Cobalt out of the Congo and
there's 15
000 black people digging with their
hands and hammers to try and get this
toxic chemical out are we oppressing
we're oppressors right now there's
there's reparations right now if you
want it but look like here's my point
you go back to the 1700s when this when
there was what was it like four million
people or two million people who lived
in the United in the United States this
area that we call the United States it
was like 2 million it was like some
ridiculously small number so are you
really being are you really an oppressor
if the people can just go build a log
cabin and hunt for food
like everyone else is doing like if I
understand the Native Americans would
eventually lose land and there was
confident in that regard that's war is
it if someone goes to war with someone
else over resources do we call one side
the oppressor
going back we don't we we never did but
I mean slavery's not War slavery is just
taking people and forcing them to work
for you right so my point is as it
pertains to obviously not slavery the
point I'm bringing up is the idea that
white people were always oppressors
certainly there are white people who
literally did oppress other people the
Romans you know what I mean the Romans
white people in general are not
oppressors that's critical race Theory
the idea that white people specifically
are oppressors and non-whites are
oppressed like see that's literally
that's not how most of my liberals
they're wrong they don't read the books
I I gotta say this is the problem we
have the books here like we like I can
show you you know this this book which
is in grade schools which depicts a a
non-binary woman receiving a [ __ ] and
they give to kids to read and she talks
about her severe psychological trauma
and abuse we actually had multiple books
from critical race theorists that we've
gone through and read and and you know
you'll say my liberal friends don't view
it that way it's like well they're wrong
they're not reading it yeah like so I I
get what you're saying but I feel like
if you're gonna write a bill Banning
critical race Theory you don't just say
critical race there you outline exactly
what is deemed very fair point and
that's what Donald Trump did when he
banned critical race there he didn't say
critical race theory he said any any
training that would would argue a
certain race is better than another race
Etc and things like that that's what he
actually had it was the I forgot which
off the legal office for the White House
wrote this thing up he signed the
executive order and all it basically
said was it is illegal under the Civil
Rights Act Title VII to discriminate the
basis of race therefore and then Joe
Biden rescinded that and allowed these
companies to continue discriminating in
the basis of race but but these bills
are very Broad and and I think that we
can agree that if the language was
defined enough to be able to say this is
this is considered critical race Theory
this is not I think we'd agree that yeah
this this can be a can be a law but I
think when you leave it open to the
courts and then you have teachers
getting sued you have you have parents
attacking teachers I I think it it kind
of it opens up in a whole can of worms
that isn't really necessary when you can
actually go after the teachers
themselves based on other things like
like something like that the the teacher
can criticize the teacher can be
criticized could be fired on an
individual basis I completely agree and
I think one of the problems is that
parents see the stuff and they don't Sue
it's like if they're some some parents
do if they went to your kid and said
white people are bad okay that's racist
that's a violation of the Civil Rights
Act Title VII file your file your
lawsuit get the book pulled instead we
get a lot of like Community complaints
and stuff like that which has has borne
fruit but I think lawsuits are the way
to go we did see however with books like
genderqueer when parents go to school
board meetings and read the book they
get ejected for reading pornographic
material in public like the the board
freaks out and says stop stop stop you
can't say these things here and they're
like then why are you giving it to our
kids in school I feel like it's super
important to teach about critical race
theory that it's important that people
know what it is any kind of political or
philosophy Theory you should have
classes like for college kids or high
school kids like political philosophy on
critical race but indoctrinating
especially children young children like
with with any kind of ideology so I
could see Banning the indoctrination
tactics but not necessarily Banning the
ideas because we need to understand what
it is like communism you got to
understand what communism is in order to
bypass it yeah so so I I know I had a
class at Rutgers in college uh about
critical race area wasn't called
critical race Theory but it discussed a
lot of things that critical race Theory
does but I don't in grade school in
middle school we didn't learn anything
like that and I don't really think well
it's new the vast majority of classes
are they are I mean like I I mean my
kids my kids haven't learned it I have a
third year third grader but this is
another another misunderstanding the
teachers aren't coming out and saying
everybody open up critical race Theory
by Kimberly Crenshaw they're saying
everybody open up math 101 read me the
problem and the kid goes Jamal got
stopped by the police 17 times Eric got
stopped five times what percentage of
the stops were were illegal stops
against Jamal for being black no but I I
read my son's homework nothing's even
close nothing in there
like super left-leaning Community we
actually oh that has that maybe but
they're mostly most liberals wouldn't
support that and that's the problem yo
you guys aren't people that don't write
a bill don't write a bill saying that's
a separate issue I agree don't write a
bill they shouldn't have the stuff in
the schools it should be done through
the school board meetings and removed
the books are in the other room actually
Omani bought a stack of all these books
one of them was from Ibrahim candy and
it was like what's right it was it was a
book where it was a workshop book and it
opened it up and it said explain the
differences between you and like a
racially different peer or whatever and
things like that let me show you this
one man I can't even I can't even show
this on camera and it's like yeah but is
that an actual curriculum book or
something that somebody checked out I
think that's what it was turn it up in
libraries it was turning no but it was
on it was on uh like reading lists for
kids reading lists yeah and it was in
thousands of schools now I get it
there's you know hundreds of thousands I
mean what were the books we were reading
when we were in grade school Like To
Kill a Mockingbird I mean there's yeah I
mean yeah
look at this no absolutely not okay so
this is genderqueer and NPR just wrote
it right and what grade what grades had
access 12 year olds yeah I I definitely
not and so the problem is when I come
out and I go to liberals and say hey
that shouldn't be in front of kids they
say you hate gay people you're a liar
you're anti-lgbtq and I'm like I'm just
saying don't show [ __ ] to 12 year
olds are you nuts
like you know put that in the bill right
well so so this is this is the issue
this book is there's an uh they've like
you go to any of these prominent left
websites and they argue it's an
important Memoir for young queer teens
they need to read the stuff and I'm like
dude you don't need to show there's more
than just that in there that was just
one thing you know and I don't even I
don't even think I can say on YouTube
some of the other stuff we've already
talked quite a bit about it but we'll
I'll show you in the after show it's
it's insane we have this on the table
because Ian bought it a lot of
conservatives haven't even read it and
it is worse than what I just showed you
like the the trauma and abuse that's in
this book
thousands of schools at the very least
are you sure about that like 100 like I
don't I don't believe that I don't
believe their stuff this is why this is
why in Loudoun County right here we had
Parents screaming because these books
are are in grade schools I mean let me
let me see okay so so but at the same
time they're also Banning books that
aren't that
that crazy and and I when I say ban I
mean they're trying to take books out of
libraries that are that aren't that bad
and and I think is there one specific
one I I don't have I I know I've looked
at list and I I've read about them I I
didn't see gender was To Kill a
Mockingbird on there I thought I'd seen
that getting taken out I think it was I
think 1984 is also being taken take a
look at this some schools from NPR
efforts to ban books jumped and
unprecedented fourfold there's
genderqueer on their list of banned
books now why are they calling it a
Banned Book like is Hustler a Banned
Book you know what I mean like if you're
if you've got a book that depicts sexual
acts and explains how to do them would
you call it Banning a book or would you
say like we just don't allow obscene
material they're banning of books as
well so government destroys every copy
of it kind of thing are these School
libraries or public libraries the ala's
office for intellectual Freedom count at
729 challenges to library school and
Universal University materials in 2021 a
significant jump last year they noted
156. so here's what's happening uh the
total number of individual books
challenged in 2021 was
1597. uh gender careers is just one of
these books people aren't actually
challenging some of the more egregious
critical race Theory based books that
are appearing in schools the stuff that
we've actually looked at and then we
have advocacy groups coming we've
multiple times interviewed them it is
hard right so a thousand fifteen hundred
books in how many schools does it say
they're talking specifically about these
these books so when we have someone come
in here and say Here's a book that does
that math problem I explained it used to
be like a train leave Cincinnati 5 PM
and leaves New York at what point do
they crash now it's you know a black man
is beaten by the police 17 times a math
problem really like we've actually had
the book and we opened it we went
through it on this show so that that the
folks shouldn't be there I agree a
school board should just say this book
yes and laws that are in place that are
broad that could be missed that could be
interpreted by us I think we're right
leaning school board so you know and so
here's here's Here's the the the the the
the the gain that we get from this show
is
next time you come across someone
talking about something like this you
simply say I agree that shouldn't be in
the school let's let's Advance you know
getting that out and then and then
agreed whether it's a thousand schools
five thousand or ten thousand we'll just
agree okay sure not the most for you
guys not the most important issue in the
world but that shouldn't be in schools
we agree it seems like it's wrapping the
conversation back around the importance
of school boards we constantly I'm like
what is the answer because I'm looking
out there in Klaus Schwab economic Forum
Global collusion and but what's the
answer is it's local people keep telling
me I mean Luke's a huge proponent of
local local communities and stuff but
like your local school boards because I
think a lot of the problems is that
there's been very little oversight of
what the schools have been doing kids
would send them there and then eight
hours later they'd see the kid
you had a little conversation about it
but now with like video cams in the chat
in the school since covid people are
like whoa this is what they're reading
this is what they're reading I'll after
after we wrap this portion go to the
members only I'll see if I can if we we
have a big book shelf of books we'll see
if we can grab it because we have we
have stacks of these books there in
these schools but we got to go to super
chats because we're running late so if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show coming up for you which
should be good fun but let's read some
super chats all right plank says being
someone who currently holds a TS CSI
clearance I can tell you the media and
Biden are gaslighting the TF Out of
everyone who doesn't hold a clearance or
no protocols I can explain it all please
do do it well get another Super Chat in
there playing
Michael alio says I called this shortly
after Biden became president they get
rid of him after two years which can set
up a comma to be president for 10 years
in accordance with the 22nd amendment I
take Buddha judge over Kamala yeah amen
popular is so popular though everyone
loves her she's so personable and such a
great personality and definitely worked
really hard with Willie Brown to get get
where she's at culture abduction says
they should have a debate with the Hodge
twins twins versus absolutely we
actually invited him onto our podcast
but they never wrote back to us on
Twitter so Hodge Tunes if you're
watching us check your Twitter DM DM DMS
on Twitter and when you do the wide shot
or we'll come back we'll come back to
this show and it can be like but I guess
somebody has to get kicked out right
Clint Clinton says first Hodge twins now
these guys what is this twin cast now
yep that's right that's kind of weird
that it worked out that way are you guys
identical twins because you look similar
but not completely identical absolutely
better looking
now why is that is that because you got
more sunlight or something I was sitting
on his face my Mom's room
do you get mad I wrote my back did you
come out first he did it was a C-section
oh yeah they I was supposed to come out
and they took him out stole my thunder
oh nasty all right Michael Irwin says
hey Ian how do you defend the fetiverse
when sites like Mastodon seem to be
Havens for CP do we have to accept
things like that for your decentralized
internet yeah really how do you accept
the world when you know that people are
being trafficked around it um I that's a
great question that the horrors of
humanity are Exposed on the internet I
don't know if there's a so so I was
talking to you about diesel which is
dso.com decentralized social media what
they do is they have a database a
blockchain and you know all that data
can get into the blockchain but people
can flag it and the apps that are
running on that blockchain can choose
what they want to show or not so they
could say
post-flag by Tim are flagged by x amount
of people just won't show on my node so
I think there is a solution I think
we'll get there use like a government I
mean if someone posts something illegal
they should be dealt with by The
Authority but the authorities though are
aiding and abetting a lot of this stuff
which is disgusting so that's the first
place that I would look into and I want
to add this how do you defend highways
when people in cars traffic children on
highways you know what I mean like I'm
not going to blame the fediverse because
bad people do bad things we got to stop
bad people from doing bad things yeah I
mean you don't want to randomly sleep
bad things either because then you're no
for doing something bad well I mean like
we got to think about it if you're
driving on the highway and you see
someone committing a crime you report it
you know what I mean like hey yeah yeah
that's true
all right let's see
definitely check out diesel.com yeah
tell me about diesel really quick yeah
so it's decentralized social media and
and basically where you have uh the data
is actually decentralized on a
blockchain and you can have different
nodes so you can have like twitter.com
you got it brian.com we can pull up that
data and censor it however we want but
that data can never be fully censored
because it's on the blockchain anybody
can pull it up so it kind of solves this
censorship debate all right Midas says
the intent argument is invalid Comey did
the same garbage where he read intent
into a law that didn't have it Trump was
perfectly legal he was the President
Biden was VP only if he classified the
documents can he take them except for
the George Bush you know executive order
that's literally it that's the George or
if he was in a supervisory well what's
the definition what does that thing you
know I think what they're basically
saying is that if it was classified by
someone under him as he was supervising
I read it as if he classified it he
could appoint someone under him to
unclassify it at any point it's hard
like I I think it would take a judge to
to determine that you know but I don't
think there's there's not a law that
says anything about supervisory role
right so if that executive order but
isn't like doesn't explain what it is
doesn't mean a supervisor of if you're
it's your supervisor in the CIA like I
don't know so that'll be interesting to
see Plank continues I hear a lot of
speculation and false assumptions in
this convo there's plenty of people who
have active clearances in here that can
can explain everything including myself
also intent doesn't matter
well you didn't give me what I wanted
plank but thanks for well that was
because that was an old oh that was an
old one okay you're on it yeah we're not
gonna be able to see anything new from
plank until we get to the bottom
all right let's see uh a lot of people
don't like you just you know I kind of
figure that Victor Draco says the
Crescent scene Bros voices sound exactly
like what I imagine every Trump reply
guy's voice sounds like thank you both
for all you want to ask a really quick
funny story is that when I first met my
wife she called me Michael Jackson
because my voice she told her sister oh
yeah I'm going out with Michael Jackson
again tonight so I know I have a kind of
a weird voice I can't help it but hey I
think it's that weird you sing too it
sounds like mine I don't sing yeah
here's what I don't understand it's like
uh the people who are who are chatting
that they're upset you're here but who
also complain that we can't get more
Democrats to come on the show and talk
with us I'm like what do you mean this
is awesome I'm glad you guys are here
I'll come whenever you want I'll be
there whenever we should we should have
you on with some other people and we'll
have more conversations are you in
Florida too yeah we lived like four
houses from each other oh sweet yeah
Marty Smith fan Sue says the chip Act
was nothing but a transfer of taxpayer
dollars to companies not in the U.S nor
any who are coming to the U.S DC rewards
their cronies
of course I think several have come to
the U.S though
or open manufacturing plants in the U.S
I thought that was the point it was we
have to get our chip manufacturing away
from Taiwan because we're about to lose
Taiwan right I could be wrong
all right Bad Andy says Tim I appreciate
you bringing on different voices however
I'm now more concerned for the future of
this country than ever
well that wasn't the intent I think of
these deep debates with people you don't
agree with is like pulling open the
wound to see how festering it is so that
you can clean it out it's not pretty
it's never pretty that but that's the
point that's why it hasn't happened but
this is so mild like we we could have
been so much worse I mean there's other
people and so much time would like stand
up and smack the microphone I could just
walk out you know we haven't we had a
civil discussion we didn't get personal
we didn't call each other names that's
awesome I think we need more of that to
understand where where we're all coming
from so
Raymond g Stanley Jr says krasenstein
Brothers thank you for coming you stated
Trump lied about the docks that's a lie
you say Biden apprehended more illegals
than Trump well duh it's porus you say
we need 87 000 more IRS agents why so
his his attorney lied about the docs
representing him she signed a
certification saying all the docs have
been turned over and we've looked
everywhere so was she just wrong we
didn't talk about taxes well I mean I
mean she didn't have to be signed she
should say we still haven't looked
everywhere so what if she thought they
looked everywhere that this is the issue
with perjury it's like how do you prove
someone yeah that's true I mean well
let's talk about the 87 000 agents you
think we need more IRS agents you know
like I I do think that we need to catch
tax sheets corporations that are not
spending but you don't need a seven
thousand agents I don't know we do I I I
don't talk to poor people more than they
do rich people I don't I think that if
we have that many more agents I think
they have to it has to be in a way that
they're going to be going after the
wealthy not the middle I mean that's
what Biden to the intent is is he going
to ensure that somehow who knows put it
in a bill and what's going on but then a
republican is going to take over and
he's going to weaponize those IRS agents
against you guys right do you guys want
those you know no we we do know they do
it all the time they do it all the time
Republicans are now super angry about
empowering the intelligence agencies
because they're going after Trump and
they're like oh no what have we done
well 10 years ago you guys thought this
would be a good idea and Democrats
warned you and then you had like Harry
Reid with the nuclear option and the
Senate and confirmations and then
McConnell was like we warned you and it
it just you know when it comes to the
IRS I don't know how they're going to
handle like uh Panamanian bank accounts
those things are off and cryptocurrency
all that stuff you know they're gonna go
after all the poor people just like they
are already
definitely don't agree with that
all right let's grab some more
Carol Miller says this episode proves
Michael malice right we need a peaceful
divorce we are looking at the same
screen and seeing two different movies
not sure how long this can keep up and I
think that's due to confirmation bias
you see what you want to believe you
believe what you want to see I think
it's uh partly yes I agree but I think
you know going to the cultural issues
there's a big component like you guys
were saying you don't care that much
about social issues but well I do that
are you I forgot how you said
conservatives care too much about them
yeah I think that they they blow them
out of proportion sometimes I think they
take a low number of issues and make it
out to paint a picture of the entire
Democratic Party
and and I think that the left does the
same to the right as well for other
things so I I don't think it's a I think
I mean it's how you get an advantage
that's how you convince people not to
vote for their party is by
fear-mongering I I think both parties do
it but I mean if you take a look at um
how Democrats vote they vote in lockstep
right and they brag about it like we're
unified and we all vote for the exact
same things blue no matter who yeah so
it's like if there is an issue that
we're concerned with as it pertains to
free speech for instance it's a social
issue yeah but it's the fabric of like
big Tech censorship going on for over a
decade and you brought it up and you
were smeared and lied about I had so
many big institutions universities make
up fake stories about me and then it's
like oh you're blowing a small thing out
of proportion it's like well look where
we are 10 years later the the government
intervened to subvert an election okay
so so but but what do you think the
solution is is the solution for the
government to intervene and say hey
these corporations can't be censoring
people I I think it goes both ways so
you can have the government saying
corporations who are private companies
can't create their own rules isn't that
going again
failing their free speech no I still
have free speech that's not what it's
called negative versus positive so the
government can say you can't do a thing
right now what they're doing is they're
saying you can do a thing the government
right now says that big Tech platforms
have the right to censor anything they
find objectionable and be completely
free of any liability that is a
government protection there should be a
government restriction hey we can't tell
you what you have to say but you cannot
tell people what they can't say but you
still have your sensor somewhere right
like scams or
pornography but right what's when is it
illegal do you wait for a judge to
decide on yes okay you do but then
you're going to have child pornography
what if you don't know you are I don't
know I I can't agree with that citizen
can make a citizen's arrest right and if
you're wrong you face civil penalties
what would happen if a guy went out with
pictures of child abuse on a big sign
and stood in the middle of the street
are are you going to walk up and be like
the owner of the street there's no owner
of the street the police will have to
come and arrest him and take those and
you have a social media is so much
larger it's going to be such a slower
process and a cop coming and arresting
somebody versus people have people have
a right to have uh due process it's also
not the Public Square it's it's a it's a
private company well I think there can
be debate over that but but laws in the
past courts in the past have said that
shopping malls aren't considered public
swears I don't really see a reason why
Twitter would legally be a Public Square
and what if you wanted to create your
own Community Tim casts whatever freedom
is down and yeah there you go and you
don't want to have certain content like
should you not be able to have that
right yes so there's two things the size
of the platform and the initial terms of
the platform Twitter says we're the Free
Speech wing of the Free Speech party all
are welcome when I when I was talking
with vegetate and Jack Dorsey they
repeatedly said we defend Free Speech
lie lie lie AI if you're going to lie to
people to come on your platform and then
set ideological parameters for speech
you're lying if I want to create you
know you know skateboard forum.com where
the only thing that's a lot of
skateboard talking if you deviate we're
Banning you that's that I told you the
rules before you got here Twitter is now
saying the rules are you can't say these
certain things but that's where the
issue of size comes into play you've got
when you've got a massive stadium open
to the public that can seat 100 000
people
but the people who are running the front
gate have banned one political faction
from coming in and they say don't worry
there's a high school football field
across the street you can rally there
it's like well you have nowhere that's
legal though right they can ban I'm
saying like in a public place I'm it's
analogy right if Twitter has become I'll
put it this way if the president was
speaking
in a stadium with the doors open to the
public I do not believe a private entity
should be able to Bar someone for
private reasons there should only be
legal reasons yeah I mean that's a
that's a decent opinion but I mean it
still comes down to government speech
and like Trump he blocked us on Twitter
yeah and we were actually part of a
lawsuit with a knight Institute and they
he was basically forced by a judge to
unblock us that's right and if that if
you agree with that precedent then you
would also but he was the government but
he was a government official so it was
it was the government official is
blocking my right to speech on his and
what if he had Jack Dorsey block you
instead
no no so so what they're doing is
they're saying hey Twitter this is
against your term as a service you
should you should remove this and they
interpret their terms as they see fit
right but but that's different than them
saying hey Twitter if you don't block
this content or ban this person we're
gonna shut you down what do you think
would happen if you went to a guy and
said I'm Gonna Leave This suitcase with
ten thousand dollars right here on this
desk would be a shame if my neighbor got
whacked have a nice day you think
they're going to be alike you didn't
just order it and they're going to rest
no no yeah I I understand though no
judge is going to look at what they're
doing the government going to Twitter
and saying here's a list of people
who've broken the rules get rid of them
and then be like well that was just
actually them moderating for three of us
so what happens when Congress calls Jack
Dorsey to testify is that intimidation
as well well how is how I mean like
causing me to testify and you know let's
say McCarthy stands up and says what
you're doing to Democrats isn't right or
two Republicans isn't right you never
ban Democrats and then he goes and bans
he bans the Democrat like is that like
there's a difference between you are
acting in a biased Manner and here's a
list of names that broke your rules yeah
but we're not saying you must delete
them like so yeah I want someone rid me
of this priest yeah we know that I mean
I mean that that's a fair argument I I
think that they're pressured but at the
same time it's not going to hold up to
to Legal standards there's not gonna
that you can't say that this is actually
abridging somebody's First Amendment you
can say that it's immoral you can say
that it's not right I think Twitter
screwed up multiple times I'm pretty
sure uh under precedent this this has
already been decided determined to have
to be a constitutional violation I I
don't think it will and we'll see what
happens
against a website uh not website but I'm
pretty sure there's something having to
do with like radio stations the
government came in and said hey this is
you know we personally feel that this
goes against your company's policies or
whatever or like I mean I I'd be
interested the government can't use a
private entity
or advocate for the remote like
suppression of someone's speech rights
or things like that well I mean they
issue subpoenas though right yeah what's
wrong with that they're requesting you
turnover documents and the judge has to
sign off on it well not not really into
the process well that's a search warrant
would be a judge signing off but a
subpoena I believe you can get like a
Clark or something there's a difference
between that and the government
going to someone and saying
oh won't someone rid me of this priest
that's what they're doing in fact when
it came to Alex Berenson was more
egregious than that they were saying
like why haven't you banned him yet and
he'd even break the rules so that right
there and Twitter was forced to
reinstate him because they were like
yeah Alex actually didn't break any
rules I I'm not I'm not really for
censorship I I think that Twitter
screwed up massively I I wasn't for the
New York Post article getting getting
deleted I I think that Twitter screwed
up I think that the FBI I think that
that Congress I think they overstepped I
don't think that it's gonna I don't
think ultimately there's gonna be a
judge or a court case that rules that
this actually a bridge anybody's First
Amendment rights I think it was wrong I
don't think that it was illegal uh Alex
Berenson already won
breaking the First Amendment not
abridging the first that would be a
civil case no a First Amendment to only
only eight against against the
government yes it's a civil lawsuit it's
not a criminal lawsuit civil and
criminal I I don't think he won a
lawsuit saying that his first amendment
rights were Abridged by the government
it was a it was a settlement with like
undisclosed terms but what what
eventually came out was that the
government went to Twitter and said why
haven't you banned this guy Twitter then
banned him and then he filed a lawsuit
saying he broke no rules and they were
in breach of yeah so but but it wasn't
his his victory in that case wasn't the
government admitting being pointed
default right yeah I mean it's gonna be
so hard to get a judge who say that's a
bridge that's going to set that
precedent Louisiana and Missouri
lawsuits right now are moving the
direction so it may very well be I mean
the stuff that's I'm interested to see
what happens like it will be interesting
he follows all right let's go ahead try
and grab some more because we need to
get more Super chats Brett Bullard says
work in semiconductor industry chips Act
is transfer of wealth from state to
wealthiest industry in the world chosen
winners by government in a free
enterprise Society Luke speak up why do
you like chips Act
I never said I like the chips act yeah
Luke why do you like the government so
much how dare you without those words
don't say that I think it's it's a
larger kind of geopolitical move to kind
of isolate Taiwan so it doesn't become
such an important Lynch uh linchpin when
it comes to the bigger kind of deciduous
trap that's unfolding between China and
the United States so the chips in
science but anytime the government gets
involved in the economy I think it's
it's absolutely for the benefit of the
super rich who really control government
and uh anytime the government's in in
finance I say get the hell out so I'm
with you
all right Dylan Ennis says the U.S would
be better if we were still Drilling in
the U.S and Russia wouldn't be in
Ukraine because the U.S would be
dominant in the oil market so it
wouldn't be worth the money for Russia
well I think Russia's foray into the
Ukraine was inevitable after the Soviet
Union gave uh uh Sebastopol to Ukraine
on the breakup because they they
neutered Russia's ability to get into
the Mediterranean and to prevent them to
from becoming a global trade power uh
and now we're just seeing like that's
what happens when you partition
countries same thing would have a Treaty
of Versailles by Germany invaded Poland
you split off part of the country and
then they're like that's my country Lisa
um president I guess yeah about an hour
ago Lisa Marie Presley died Cardiac
Arrest 54 years old about an hour ago so
I had to hear it a lot of cardiac
arrests you know in the news lately many
damn climate change probably climate
change you know the temperatures are uh
are changing what is it called
um what was it called wet bulb wet
balls yeah bad for you yeah dry them up
guys
all right
stuck in VA says these two are typical
Florida Democrats I have family in
Florida that are MSNBC Democrats and
they have no actual real life exposure
to what is happening in other parts of
the country
to them what we see with CRT ESG Wilton
Etc every day in the Northeast and
western states are extreme examples they
are unknowingly influenced by the fact
that Florida conservative policy is
protecting them from the nonsense going
on in other states I'm from Jersey so I
grew up in they're one of the worst when
was the last time you were in Jersey
though uh I I moved to Florida 15 years
ago but I I go back it doesn't surprise
me to think that people would be
insulated from things like genderqueer
because I never probably would never
even know about if I was on this show
people come in and they tell me about
this stuff and I'm like oh my God are
you serious all right here's the last
one caliph Harvey says peaceful divorce
there is absolutely zero Common Ground
anymore time to separate the problem is
they'll simply invade our states like
what's happening on the southern border
yikes man okay well if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends become a
member at timcast.com we're going to
have a good fun this Saturday in DC's
Freedom Plaza skating around I'm I'm
wondering if like too many people show
up are we even gonna be able to skate as
it is maybe let's be a huge crowd of
people all like yelling or something but
uh it'll be fun either way head over to
timcast.com we're gonna have that
members only show you can follow the
show at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast everywhere you can
follow at timcast news on Twitter do it
uh Crescent scenes you guys want to
shout anything out uh just follow our
YouTube crashing KS just search for
crafting we're interviewing mostly
right-wing people so and we have Carpe
donctum uh our first show and it's
called Uh dismantling Division and we
just seek to have conversations with
people we disagree with like Tim Tim you
could come on the show and in it'll be
like in six months you guys will be
wearing Maga hats and you'll be like
maybe maybe that maybe we're gonna
transplant that I doubt that yeah and I
just want to give a shout out to Gadsden
hats who our co-founders at nftz dot me
Mark Tyne Van Halen boss and Val Van
Halen just want to say hi I know they're
watching
right on are you guys on Twitter we are
at Ed crassen e d k r a s s e n n at
krastenstein well thank you guys so much
for coming it was a great conversation
we we kept it civil which I think is
awesome we didn't agree which is fine I
don't have to enforce My Views I or will
on you and I think having more of these
conversations is more important than
ever I love having some of these
conversations myself on youtube.com
forward slash we are change today I did
a video about the 5 000 gestapo agents
coming to Davos Switzerland along with
the governor of Illinois lots of things
happening in Davos at the world economic
Forum did a full video on that plus a
lot more youtube.com forward slash we
are change see you there just put it
together that you guys are the Crescent
Steins
does it literally either one say crass
and steam say crassenstein either one I
think my mom says one my dad says other
so okay it's a lot easier it's actually
it's Ed crescentstein and Brian Crescent
exactly they're not related yeah it
turns out uh well I want to remind
people to go to Desoto com if they
haven't yet DSO yes we're not affiliated
with them we're just building on there
and we've been members of it since
getting kicked off Twitter so it's
decentral I moved towards decentralized
social networking essentially D so uh
thanks for coming guys this is really
great yeah thanks for having us it I
think it's important that we can get
together and just talk even though we
disagree on a lot of things I know we
did agree too on a lot of things so
thank you yeah we only talk about stuff
we disagree with though you know oh for
sure and this and look we we invite
people who are Democrat liberal left all
the time very few will ever come and sit
down and have these conversations so I
appreciate you guys coming yeah I'm
looking forward to getting the
authoritarian and Narco tyranists to
come on and talk about the world
economic Forum I'm ready
Schwab in the gang let's roll it would
be cool if Cloud Schwab agreed to come
on and then he sits down wearing his
weird robe and he's like let me just
tell you why you're going to lose
some fun yeah I'm into it all right all
right bye everyone hey guys I'm Sergio
com I agree it's really nice to have
conversation where it's civil we're able
to discuss things we're are not here
trying to accuse other things call each
other names get muckracking and
everything it just doesn't go anywhere
it's it's so annoying and regressive so
I appreciate you guys coming thank you
very much I see all these conversations
happen in front of me so really nice
change thank you guys all right
everybody we'll see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out
cheers